مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم كل سنه وحضراتكم
طيبين اسال الله ان يعيد عليكم هذه الايام
بالخير واليمن والبركات ان شاء الله وعلى
كل الناس
لا في ناس دخلت بدري اهي
احنا الصوت والصوره تماما دول
على بركه الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الاسئله مش جايه
معايا من الاول ليه
هو اول سؤال حسن في المانيا
انا شايف اول سؤال حسن في المانيا مظبوط
طيب تمام في رايي ان الازمه الاسرائيليه
مش هتوصل لابعد من كده
وهيثبتوا ان هم فعلا دوله ديمقراطيه ولا
شعبيه حق الرفض والتظاهر وطبعا هيفضلوا
علاقات متفقين علاقات قتل الفلسطينيين هل
هذا صحيح لا يا حسن هو الراي اللي انت
بتقوله ده هو راي مستقر لدى كل من يمكن ان
تساله لانه في قناعه في دول كتيره وبذات
في الشرق الاوسط انه اسرائيل دايما متفوقه
وقادره تتجاوز ازمتها وانه الانكسارات دي
بتحصل في الدول الاخرى اللي هو احنا يعني
او غيرهم وان هم كيان كده لا يمكن كسره
يعني
ده سبب انه ما حدش بيتوقع ان في اذى هيحصل
هناك
طبعا دي صوره فيها بعض المبالغه وبعض
الدقه يعني لان في الاخر هم عندهم ازمه
يمكن تجاوزها مؤقتا بس حقيقه الامر الازمه
عميقه جدا مش بالضروره تادي لانهيار
الدوله مش بالضروره تادي يعني الى حاجه
كده خياليه ولكن المساله مش سهله على
السطح واظن ده سؤال حسن هيكون مشترك مع
اسئله اخرى كثيره على السطح احنا بنتكلم
على ازمه
على خلاف تشريعي اللي هو محاوله الحد من
السلطه القضائيه
تحول الى خلاف دستوري
وخلصته للتذكير بالناس لتذكير الناس انه
حكومه نتنياهو ارادت ان هي تعمل مجموعه من
التشريعات
بمنتهى البساطه للاختصار ان هي تتحكم في
اللجنه المكونه من تسع اشخاص التي تختار
قضاه المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل والتي
تماثل المحكمه الدستوريه ليس لديهم محكمه
دستوريه لانه ليس لديهم دستور ودي قصه
تانيه انما هذه هي المحكمه التي تعادل
المحكمه الدستوريه اذا هم مرروا هذا
التشريع
هيتحكموا في القضاه الحكومه المنتخبه اللي
هي داخل الكنيست هي لا تتحكم اذا تحكموا
في هذه المحكمه يبقى لن يكون هناك اي سلطه
في اسرائيل تستطيع ان هي
تجهد القوانين التاليه التي يخططون لها
وهي مجموعه كبيره من القوانين بعضها ده
ابسط حاجه بيخدم اشخاص في الحكومه حتى
يقوموا بسن قوانين تبرئهم من تهم هم
متورطين فيها حوالي تلات وزراء منهم اصلا
نتنياههم
ده ده الابسط في المساله اتنين مجموعه من
القوانين الاخرى بقى اللي تشرع الاستيطان
بصوره اكثر اللي تعطيهم الحق مثلا في
اصدار او تطبيق حكومه الاعدام على
الفلسطينيين اللي بيقوموا باي اعمال
مقاومه كما يسمونها هم ارهاب الى اخره
فانه يعطي حقوق اكتر للجماعات الدينيه
وهكذا
القصه دي في جوهرها احنا بنتكلم على دوله
بتكلم على هويتها
الاعتراضات جوه اسرائيل بيقولوا ان
المجموعه دي سمح لها بتمرير هذه التشريعات
هتاخدنا في سكتها فين سكتها دوله دينيه
بالدرجه الاولى
والانيه لان هي دوله دينيه ودوله قوميه
يعني بيتكلم على يعني زي ما يقول مثلا كده
انا روسي انا
انا الماني انا انجليزي دي حاجه خطيره جدا
فكره القوميه خطيره على اي بلد
بتتحكم فيه وبطبيعي ان هي بتنزاح على
العالم الخارجي فاحنا بنتكلم على ازمه
عميقه جوه اسرائيل مش من السهل ان يكون
لها حل ابدا لاحظ السيناريوهات الموجوده
اخويا حسن اذا هو انتصر في هذه المعركه
وهذا امر مشكوك فيه هنبقى قدام هذه
النموذج المتطرف جدا اللي قال الغرب
وحلفاء اسرائيل اكثر ما قال العالم العربي
واذا فشل وتم عزله او اقالته فهتفضل
اسرائيل داخل اسرائيل في حاله فوضى لان هم
في حاله فوضى داخليه من حوالي ثلاث سنين
او اكثر لانه ما فيش اتفاق على هويه
اسرائيل في تيار ديني قادر يفوز بالاصوات
بس النخب اللي موجوده جوه اسرائيل لا تريد
لهذه المجموعه التي تفوز في الانتخابات ان
يكون لها
كارت على بياض او شيك على بياض تتصرف كما
تريد لانها اذا تصرفت كما تريد هتعمل دوله
دينيه لن لا يمكن ان تقبل في المجتمع
الدولي
انا اطلت انا اسف يا حسن هل سيكون هناك
ربيع عربي اخر هل الربيع العربي ثورات ام
مجرد مظاهرات مثل ما يحدث في كل الدول
عندنا تسوء الاوضاع المعيشيه وهل تتفق ان
عصر الثورات التي تغير الانظمه قد انتهى
لا لا اتفق ابدا اذا اذا كان في ثوره زي
ما انت بتقول ما احنا لسه بنتكلم في
اسرائيل ما هو كان ممكن بسهوله جدا اذا
استمرت المساله اسبوع ولا حاجه كانت نياهو
يتم خلعه كن اللي ينتج عن كده شيء ايجابي
او سلبي دي قصه تانيه لكن في اي زمان وفي
اي عصر اذا حصلت انتفاضه كبيره ثوره كبيره
قوه وازنه في اي مجتمع ضد حكومتها مش
هتستمر الحكومه ده يعني منطقي
الفرق بس في طول المده انا شايف ان الصوره
اللي عندي انا مهتزه هل الصوره هي عندك
انت تمام وكله طيب الحمد لله
الجزء الاولاني من سؤالك اخونا تشاد هل
سيكون هناك ربيع عربي اخر اتمنى لا انما
يعني هيبقى ايه بقى انت بتتكلم بيحصل
الربيع العربي ده فين يعني
لا يعني ممكن ممكن في بعض الدول يكون فيها
اضطرابات ممكن بس ربيع عربي بمعنى اللي
شفناه كده في 2011
وينتقل من دوله لثانيه لا ما اعتقدش يعني
لماذا تجمل او تحمل مش متاكده بشوف السياق
دول الخليج وانت تعلم انهم لا يزالون
حلفاء مهمين لامريكا
وان قرار عدم زياده انتاج النفط يصل في
مصلحه او يصب في مصلحه شركات النفط
الامريكيه وان امريكا اكبر منتج ومصدر
النفط في العالم ولم يزيد الانتاج هو علي
انت بتقول لماذا تجمل يعني انا اجمل ده
المعنى اللي انا فاهمه انا جملت فين دول
الخليج انا ده كتير من اصدقاء الخلايا
زعلانين لكن عموما يعني اذا كنت بتتكلم في
سياق ان انا قلت ان هم خدوا سياسه مستقله
فيما يتعلق بالانتاج يعني ده صحيح يعني مش
عارف اتحرك شايفها مختلفه ليه دول الخليج
ودول عربيه ودول شرق اوسطيه زي طبعا تركيا
وزي ايران وزي الدول العربيه كثيره في
الازمه الاخيره على عكس الصوره النمطيه
اللي مستقره في اذهان ناس كثيره ان هم دول
خاضعه للقوى الكبرى هذا غير دقيق الدول
ديت مع الوقت بقى عندهم تراكم خبرات كبير
وعندهم قدره ان هم يدركوا ان هم دول
اقليميه او دول صغيره انا بتكلم على
الخليج بس بتكلم على كل دول العالم العربي
لكن عندهم قدره على موازنه مصالحهم مع
مصالح القوى الكبيره مش بس كده كاوتاو
وخلاص يعني تسليم لا والامثله على كده
كتيره يعني
انت بتتكلم على دول الخليج دول الخليج وهي
يعني
دول لها وضع خاص جدا عدد سكان صغير ثروات
كبيره محل طمع من دول اقليميه ومن دول
العالميه ومع ذلك في الفتره الاخيره انت
بتتكلم بتوازن بتعمل علاقات مع الصين
وتعمل علاقات مع روسيا وبتعمل علاقات مع
الولايات المتحده وبترفض طلبات لهؤلاء
وطلبات لهؤلاء وهكذا يعني ده مالوش علاقه
بالتجبيل ولا حاجه اجملهم ليه يعني
جندي محمد هل كل ما يحدث الان من مشاكل في
الاقتصاد هو تمهيد للصدورع والعملات
الرقميه من البنوك المركزيه
وهل فعلا هتكون وسيله للتحكم ومحاسبه
المواطنين كما يحدث في الصين
في معارضه كبيره للموضوع في امريكا انا لو
انت بتتكلم على العملات الرقميه اللي هي
يعني
العملات اللي بتصدر من البنوك المركزيه مش
بتتكلم على الكريبتو
يعني كان حضرتك معك تذكره التذكره دي انت
هتحضر بها حفله في الاوبرا او في اي مكان
ممكن يبقى معك التذكره ورقيه وممكن يبقى
معك التذكره رقم يعني على الموبايل في
الحالتين انت عندك مقعد موجود محجوز باسمك
ليوقع على الارض هتوصل له لو معاك تذكره
ورقيه وهتوصل له لو كان معك تذكره رقميه
فالاختلاف في الشكل بس
والقواعد اللي بتحكم عمليه طباعه النقود
الورقيه هتحكم عمليه اصدار
النقود الرقميه فهي تكنولوجيا مختلفه ده
في سوره البسيطه انما ما فيش شك ان لما
هيبقى في تكنولوجيا رقميه هيبقى في
يعني توابع اخرى بعضها الان يعني عليه
علامات استفهام وبعضه لسه ما ظهر لناش
يعني طريقه تعامل البنوك مثلا هتحتفظ
بالاموال دي ازاي هتتصرف فيها ازاي
ولايه الاموال هتبقى لمين اذا كان في
البنوك هي حطاها فيزيكال تحت ايديها يعني
امور كثيره انا شخصيا مش مطلع عليها
مش عارف في المساله بالظبط ومش متاكد انه
الناس المتخصصين شايفين الصوره كلها كامله
لكن ردا على سؤالك انا مش متخيل ان في
احداث في العالم او في الاقتصاد مقصوده
بذاتها او ان هي
يعني ان الهدف منها في النهايه وصل للعمله
الرقميه يعني ما اعتقدش يعني او هكذا مبلغ
علمي مش عارف ايه العلاقه يعني عاوز اتاكد
بس ان انت ما تقصدش الكريبت والكرنسيز
اللي هم ناس بيصدروا عملات وخلاص زي
البيتك
وين والحاجات دي دي قصه تانيه خالص يعني
ده موضوع تاني خالص ده ناس بتصدر من
دماغها كده وعندهم
تصور مختلف في حياتهم يعني انا طبعا
اتكلمت على
وقلت فيها ما لم يقله مالك في الخمر
اضافه
الى عدم ممانعه اسرائيل
في سبيل الضغط كي لا تعود امريكا لاتفاق
النووي سامحني لم افهم السؤال يا علي
لم افهم السؤال سامحني السلام عليكم هل
الهند في طريقها
ايزو في طريقها لتصبح الصين الجديده من
حيث السياده العالميه والله مش واضح لي
يعني انت بتتكلم الهند طبعا دوله مهمه
وكبيره بس لو خدنا بس ان الارقام بسيطه
يعني هتلاقي الهند الجي دي بي بتاعها يعني
بتتكلم على حوالي ثلاثه تريليون او اقل من
3 تريليون دوله تعداد سكانها حوالي واحد
واربعه من عشره مليار بني ادم فثلاثه
تريليون دي عن اقتصاد
حوالي 60% من اقتصاد اليابان او حاجه كده
يعني بالنسبه للاقتصاد المانيا اللي هم
بيوصلوا لاربعه ونص وخمسه تريليون دولار
لا يعني ايه تبقى تساوي ايه بالنسبه للصين
تساوي يعني الصين كانت في 2020 ولا 2021
اظن كانت بتتكلم على 18 تريليون
اعتقد اخر رقم باكبر يعني
فبنتكلم انه لا ما زال الاقتصاد الهندي
ايوا يعني في وضع افضل ولكنها بعيده يعني
بعيده كثيرا عن احنا نتكلم على ان تبقى
قوه عظمى انما هي الهند بحكم حجمها
وموقعها ممكن تلعب دور مهم في التوازنات
الدوليه يعني امريكا تبقى عاوزه تجتذبها
والصين عاوزه تكتذبها وهي تحاول تستفيد من
الامريكا وحاوزه تستفيد من الصين خصوصا في
الصراع الدائر في منطقه محيطي الهندي
والهادي افتح الخريطه ودور على المحيط
الهندي والهادي اللي بيدور فيها صراع
الكبير قوي بين الصين والولايات المتحده
وقوه اخرى تابعه للولايات المتحده مش
تابعه يعني صديقه للولايات المتحده
هتجد ان دي منطقه حيويه جدا والصراع
الاكبر بيدور فيها
وعليه فان الهند الفريق اللي هي هتدعمه
هتكون لها
تاثير كبير في توازنات القوى في السنوات
القادمه يعني
هل هناك محاوله لانشاء حكومه عالميه ممكن
تطبيق ده اخونا تشاهد برضه حكايه الحكومه
العالميه دي انا اسمع عنها وانا يعني
صغير يعني
الاعتقاد بان في حكومه عالميه ناس بيقعدوا
سر كده ويديروا الحكومه بالصوره احيانا
بتظهر لنا
يعني تكون حاجه صعبه شويه انما ما في شك
من غير نظريات مؤامره ولا حاجه انه ايه
المقصود بحكومه عالميه انه تكون في مجموعه
من المؤثرين اللي هم عندهم قدره انه
يدفعوا شعوب ودول العالم لمسارات تناسب
مصالحهم بالشكل ده اللي هو العام ما فيش
شك ان في ناس مؤثرين وانت لما يكون عندك
واحد ثروته 300
مليار دولار
او تقل زي ايلون ماسك ده وعنده قدره
لاطلاق صواريخ في الفضاء وعنده قدره على
انه يعمل يتحكم في صناعات حيويه ومؤثره
جدا في كل مكان ما فيش شك ان ارادته
ومصالحه اللي هي تتشابك مع مصالح اخرين
يقدر انه
ياخذ العالم في اتجاهات كتيره هو مش
عاوزها العالم مش عاوزها يعني ممكن يساعد
في نجاح حكومات واسقاط حكومات يقدر انه
يغير مسار احداث ما هو غير في مسار الحرب
الاوكرانيه بتوفير وسيله للتواصل بين
الجنود الاوكران عملت مشاكل كبيره للروس
يعني
فانا بدي ده كمثال يعني وبالتالي ممكن
يعني بالمعنى ده ان في ناس مؤثرين من
الساسه من الرجال المال من الناس اللي
عندهم وسائل الاعلام
ومؤثره يقدروا طبعا ياثروا في العالم اذا
كان هذا المعنى المقصود
فشيء منطقي يعني لكن حكومه بقى زي ما كنا
بنقرا زمان وبيجتمعوا حكومه ال 12 وحكومه
السبعه وبيتقابلوا في مكان كل سنه
كلام لا معنى له يعني في تقديري
يا ريت تكتر من البثوث حتى ولو نص ساعه
علشان الدنيا خربانه من كل حته عمر
بخربانه يبقى انت مصري يعني كلمه خربانه
اقصد يعني اللهجه من كل حته ومش بنفهم
حاجه من غيرك وبرضو البث مش محتاج تحضير
زي الحلقات ماشي يا عمر تحت امرك
بس ان شاء الله ما تبقاش خربانه يا عمر
تفائلوا بالخير ان شاء الله كده انا عملت
كده فجت الاسئله كلها راحت كتيره نرجع
تاني انا كنا عند عمر ماشي كده تمام
التعبير نحن غير جاهزون للديمقراطيه ده
تشاد جاب بدري
وخد كل الاسئله
طب اسمك ايه يا شهد انت بس يعني يا ريت
تقول لنا اسمك يعني نحن غير جاهزون
للديمقراطيه وافترض ان الديمقراطيه هي
الاسلوب الافضل الحكم وهذا تثبت انه خاطئ
خاطئ الغرب
يتراجع عن الديمقراطيه يتجه الاستبداد فهي
لم تعد تحقق تطلعات المواطنين ما انت لما
تقول نحن غير جاهزون احنا مين ما انا هنا
الاصدقاء مشتركين جايين من دول كثيره فهنا
في ناس في الولايات المتحده او في ناس في
اوروبا
وفي ناس في اسيا وناس مصر داخلين على
المباشر فانت قول انت منين ونتناقش اذا
كنت بتتكلم على العالم العربي فدي قصه
يعني قلناها كتير في الدول العربيه على
اختلاف ظروفها نسبيا يعني مساله
الديمقراطيه دي بمعنى ان انت تروح
للصناديق الانتخابات وتكون في احترام
للصناديق الانتخابات ويكون في فروق حقيقيه
بين المرشحين ويكون المرشح ورا حزب مؤثر
والحزب ده
هيرشح واحد وانت هتروح هتختار حد مختلف
وهتحترم ارادتك وهيحصل تداول سلطه سلس
الكلام ده لا احنا مش جاهزين ليه بصراحه
يعني وزي يعني احنا مش جاهزين ليه على
مستويات كتيره ده صحيح لكن ده مش معناه ان
احنا مش ممكن يحصل لنا اكيد احنا مش شعوب
مختلفه عن بقيه البشريه ما احنا اتكلمنا
في القصه دي قبل كده كتير ولكن العمليه
بتاخد وقت انك تتجاوز الاعتبارات القبليه
انك تتجاوز الاعتبارات القبليه والعشريه
وبرضو تاثير
لما يكون
هي عمليه يعني قضيه حساسه ولكن ما فيش شك
انه صعب جدا يكون مجتمع متدين جدا ولو على
مستوى الطقوس ويتوقع ان يكون فيه
ديمقراطيه بتتكلم على حقوق المواطنه
وبيتكلم انه لا فرق بين اصحاب الديانات
المختلفه والقوميات المختلفه وانه في
بس دوله مواطنه والكل يتساوى قانون ده صعب
لانه اصحاب ما انت عارف مشكله اسرائيل
النجاح حد بيقول هو ويهودي متدين فاهم
التوراه كما يعني يراها فهما صحيحا وشايف
انه المواطنه هنا ما تنطبقش على العرب هذه
ارض اليهود كلامه اللي بيحظى بانتقال كتير
من المسلمين بيقولوا بيقول دي ارض ده بلد
المسلمين احنا الاغلبيه والباقيين عاوزين
يعيشوا وتبقا لوقاعد اهلا وسهلا مش عاوزين
مع السلامه بالمناسبه لما تقرا اكثر
متطرفين في الهند هتلاقي كده البوذيين
اللي بيقولوا كده في سريلانكا وغيرها يعني
انا قلت سريلانكا سريلانكا في اسم دوله
تانيه هربان من ذهني انا اسف
تحيه طيبه
ده اخونا
مش عارفه اقرا الاسم تحيه طيبه معك غيداء
غيداء من فلسطين سؤالي حول الوضع اسرائيل
مستقبلا فهي تستطيع تجاوز الازمه الحاليه
ولكن في ضوء ما حدث ما تاثير ذلك على
تركيبه دولتها وشعبها في المستقبل البعيد
هو في المستقبل القريب وفي المستقبل
البعيد في ازمه كبيره في اسرائيل يمكن
غيداء انت ما حضرتيش معنا من الاول
المشكله اكبر من الخلاف على وضع المحكمه
وضع المحكمه العليا لانه هو نتنياهو قال
كلام وجيه قال انتم بتقولوا لي ليه انا
بعمل عمل ما حصلش عشان نبقى في الصوره من
الاول
المحكمه العليا والسلطه القضائيه متهمه من
انصار نتنياهو ومن سنوات مضت من اليمين ان
هي بتتجاوز صلاحيتها وبتضغط على السلطات
الاخرى زكاه السلطه التشريعيه والسلطه
التنفيذيه وفي اسرائيل الوضع مختلف شويه
لان السلطه التنفيذيه
ما بتنفصلش خالص عن السلطه التشريعيه لانه
الائتلاف الحزب او الائتلاف اللي بيفوز
بيبقى مسيطر على البرلمان وكمان مسيطر على
على الحكومه يبقى السلطه التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه بتكون تقريبا مع الحزب او
الاحزاب
الفائزه في الانتخابات هم بيعتقدوا ان
احنا تعبانين وبتعمل انتخابات والناس
بتنتخبنا وفي الاخر نقدم قرارات تمثل او
طرد الشريحه الانتخاباتنا وتيجي المحكمه
العلويه تقول لنا لا ودي قصه يطول شرحها
انما
الحادث انه
هي بتقول لا ليه لانه في اختلاف عميق على
اسرائيل دي ايه اصلا هي دوله ديمقراطيه
دوله دوله مواطنه يجي الاسرائيلي العربي
الاسرائيلي المسلم الاسرائيلي الدرزي
الاسرائيلي المسيح الاسرائيلي اليهودي كله
يتساوى لا القصه دي الحقيقه محل خلاف اللي
بيقولوا الكلام ده ما يسمى باليسار
الاسرائيلي وهو طيار مش مؤثر ضعيف كان قوي
في اول نشاه اسرائيل انما دلوقتي ضعيف
وضعيف جدا وبقى له عشرين سنه الطيار
اليميني
والقومي ثم اليميني القومي اللي بيتكلموا
على ان انا اسرائيل لليهود فقط وليست
لغيرهم زي ما بقول المانيا للالمان
وامريكا للامريكان كمان
الاسرائيلي اليهودي فقط ثم بدا اين يهودي
ده هم مش عاوزين اليهود العلماني العادي
اللي هو
اسس اسرائيل وقادها لا هم عاوزين
بيتكلموا على اليهود اللي عندهم عاوزين
يحكموا التوراه في رؤيتهم وانه اليهود
والسامره اللي هي الدفه الغربيه ديت ارض
الاعطاها الله لنا فلا يمكن ابدا انها
تطرح للمفاوضات
مع اي دوله اخرى بيتكلموا على ما فيش حق
للفلسطينيين لسه وزير الماليه اللي هم
بيمثل هذا التيار بيقول لا توجد لا فيه
حاجه اسمه فلسطين ولا يعني شعب اسمه
فلسطين اصلا والكلام ده مش جديد واتكلمنا
عليه في حلقات مختلفه وكانت جولد مقير
بتقول من الستينات انا ما فيش فلسطين انا
فلسطينيه انا اللي كنت موجوده واذا كان في
ناس قعدوا فتره مؤقته لا هذا لا يعطيهم
حقا يعني انه يقولوا نحن
شعب يستحق دوله يعني بعدين المساله
بالنسبه لهم اكبر من فلسطين يعني فلسطين
دي اكبر مشكله لكن انت لما هتتكلم بقى على
حد بيقول انا حدودي هي ما وعدني الله به
هيدخل في مشاكل مع كل دول الجوار اولهم
طبعا هتكون الاردن وطبعا مصر لان هنا
بيتكلموا على اسرائيل كما رسمتها التوراه
عندهم مشاكل اصلا مع كل بقى الفئات
الاسرائيليه العاديه يعني امريكا من ضمن
الحاجات والغرب اللي منزعج ان هذا التيار
بيقول مفيش اي حقوق لا مثليين ولا متحولين
ولا الكلام ده خالص هم
رافضينه تماما ده هياثر على نظره الغرب
للمساله دي حساسه قوي بالنسبه له همم
المراه نفسها رايهم ان هي تقعد في البيت
ما تعملش حاجه ثانيه يعني بتتكلم على صوره
اقول لك على حاجه يا استاذ غيداء غيداء
مزبوط
موضوع
التحالف اللي موجود في اسرائيل واتمنى ما
اكونش اسهبت في الاجابه على سؤال وتوهت
حضرتك بتذكرني تماما لو انت مش عارف
التفاصيل اللي موجوده في اسرائيل ممكن
نفهمها احنا في عالمنا هنا لان احنا
عشناها بعيده عن اسرائيل قبل ثورات الربيع
العربي الدول اللي كان فيها تيارات
اسلاميه سواء اخوان مسلمين او بعض
الطيارات اللي هي او باسماء مختلفه يعني
او التيارات اللي هي كانت
اي طيار ديني حزب سلفي حزب وتيفرتيزي يعني
ايا كانت الاسامي دول كان لما كانت بتعقد
انتخابات حره كان في الغالب بيفوزه ممكن
يفوزوا بالاغلبيه بمقاعد عدد كبير الى
اخره اي ما تتوفر انتخابات نزيهه كانوا
عندهم القدره يوصلوا يفوزوا يوصلوا في
الانتخابات انما بمجرد ما بيوصلوا
بيلاحقوا بشده من السلطه اللي موجوده
والنخب الحاكمه مش عاوزينهم فبيحاولوا ان
هم يفشلوهم او يسقطوهم والحسبه بسيطه هم
يقولوا احنا عاوزين احنا احنا بنفوز
بالديمقراطيه وهنتعرض للقمع وهذا صحيح
طيب واللي بيقنعوهم بيقمعوهم ليه بيقولوا
لان دول اذا وصلوا هيوصلوا بالديمقراطيه
بس هيخربوا البلد وهيخربوا الديمقراطيه
ويعطلوها وهذا صحيح ايضا ففي معضله انه
الديمقراطيه يمكن ان تاتي بهؤلاء في
اسرائيل يمكن ان تاتي بهم في العالم
العربي لكن في القلب هم لا يؤمنوا الا به
ديمقراطيه ولا غيره ده بيؤمنوا
بدوله دينيه اللي بيحكم فيها مفاهمهم
وعقائدهم وفقا لفهمهم طبعا للدين اللي
احنا بنتكلم عليه اذا كان يهودي ولا
اسلامي او غيره يعني
اخونا ولف بيقول ممكن تشرح لنا الفرق بين
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه والكاثوليكيه لا
والله ربنا يخليك يا اخونا والف لست فقيها
في هذا
لصديق يعني كان
شاطر جدا اكثر من صديقي الحقيقه وكنت برجع
لهم لما اكون عاوز افهم حاجه بس انا يعني
مش انا شخص واحد للاجابه على هذا النوع من
الاسئله العقائديه
ايزو
كيف يمكن لدول ذات اقتصادات الناميه مثل
اندونيسيا ان يكون لديها ناتج محلي اعلى
من هولندا التي تعتبر اقتصاد متقدم ما انت
ما تحسبش المسائل بالشكل ده يعني انا يعني
طبعا ما كنتش عارف ان انت يعني مثلا انت
بورتو احسن الناتج المحلي ده ايه اجمالي
يعني القيمه النقديه لاجمالي ما ينتجه بلد
ما من سلع وخدمات في فتره زمنيه معينه
وليكن سنه لما يكون بلد زي اندونيسيا انا
اعتقد انه عدد سكاني حوالي 250 مليون يا
ريت تتاكدوا كده وهولندا هيكون عدد سكانها
قد ايه بلد صغير جدا انا مش واثق من عدد
سكانه لكن هيكون رقم بسيط جدا
بديه ان 250 مليون هيكون الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لهم كبير اكبر من في الغالب يعني
من دوله صغيره زي هولندا بس لما يتقسم
الناتج ده على عدد السكان لازم هولندا
تطلع غنيه ولازم اندونيسيا مش هتكون بنفس
الثراء
انا كنت بكلمكم على الهند فالهند بتتكلم
عشان الرقم حاضر في ذهني يعني لما يكون
واحد واربعه
مليار و400 مليون الناتج المحلي اليوم
حوالي ثلاثه تريليون
وبلد تاني مثلا زي اسرائيل اللي كنا
بنتكلم عليها الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لهم
حوالي 400 مليون طيب 400 400 مليار 400
مليار ولا تلاته تريليون ثلاثه تريليون
اكبر بس التلاته التريليون دول مقسمين على
مليار و400 مليون لكن 400 مليون 400 مليار
دولار الاسرائيلي مقسم على عدد لا يذكر
بالنسبه للهند يعني حي صغير في الهند ده
لازم عمليه نسبه وتناسب
ولذلك دائما كانوا مثلا يكتبوا كده مثلا
دوله تريليونيه يعني الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لها تريليون لكنها فقيره طبعا
فقيره لانه التريليون ولا الاتنين تريليون
الصين نفسها عندها مشكله انت بتتكلم على
دوله عدد سكانها تقريبا برضو واحد واربعه
مليون انما والناتج المحلي الاجمالي لها
ضخم بس ستيل امريكا
اغلب كتير هتلاقي دوله زي فرنسا دوله زي
دول الخليج اغنى ليه لانه الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لهم الصغير مقسم على عدد سكان
صغير جدا مرحبا استاذ جبيل مساء سعيد عليك
ربنا يخليك ويحفظك فادي شكرا جزيلا هل
اصبحت اسرائيل ده
ادريس هل اصبحت اسرائيل دوله فودهم ما هو
ده قلب الصراع قلب الصراع في اسرائيل على
هويه اسرائيل على فكره
قضيتين في اسرائيل مش لاقيين لهم حل
والاثنين مرتبطين ببعض نعمل ايه مع
الفلسطينيين
وهو السؤال ده اللي كان بيميز اليمين
واليسار يعني اليمين طبعا اليمين واليسار
بينهم قضايا شهيره محل خلاف
الضرائب تصاعديه ولا لا
النقابات
ده على مستوى يعني الاقتصادي يعني دور
الدوله دور الدوله يكون كبير دور الدوله
يكون صغير
قضايا مثلا في
قضايا اجتماعيه في اجهاض ما فيش اجهاض من
هذا النوع يعني انما كل القضيه دي كانت
مطروحه في اسرائيل نبقى يعني اشتراكيين
ولا راس ماليين ولا كذا انما كان السؤال
الاساسي والفارق الاساسي بين اليمين
واليسار في اسرائيل منذ نشاته هو كيف
نتعامل مع الفلسطينيين فكان اليسار بيميل
تقليديا الى التفاهم معهم مش معناه ان هم
ناس طيبين وقلوبهم هو عاوز عاوز يتفاهم
معاهم عشان ده في مصلحه اسرائيل هو شايف
انه انا لو لو الفلسطينيين اصبحت لهم دوله
وتفاهمنا معهم هيقل فرص الصراع
والاسرائيليين او اليهودي اليهود في
الدوله التي يعني يرضون بها يكونوا امنين
من
ملايين البشر اللي حاسين بالضغط والظلم
والعدوان عليهم وهيبقى قبول اسرائيل من
المجتمع الدولي اكبر
وفي مجموعه حالمه يعني يهود عندهم مبادئ
عندهم اخلاق مش قابلين بالوضع بقطع النظر
عن منافع اسرائيل يعني
وفي اليمين بدرجاته مختلفه كان عنده تصور
مختلف اللي اختلف ده اول قضيه اللي حصل
قبل ما اروح للقضيه التانيه انه في
السنوات اللي فادت اليسار ده تراجع تراجع
تراجع واليمين السعوديه يصعد يصعد
وبالتالي هو لا يرى انه للفلسطينيين يجب
ان يكون لهم حقوق اثنين اللي هو كان قومي
ما بيفكرش على اساس ديني طلع معاه اليمين
الديني اليمين الديني ده بقى مش هو مش
عاوز يصعد على اساس ان انا اسرائيل لليهود
لاحظوا ان كلمه اليهود اعتبروها كانها
جنسيه يعني تعاملوا معاه ودي حاجه غريبه
انه جنسيه يعني مش لانه هو الماني هو
اسرائيلي لا ده كمان لان انا يهودي يعني
ده ارض اليهود فقط وبالتالي هو بيبص
للتوراه وما يقوله الكتاب المقدس بالنسبه
له وعاوز يطبقه وبالتالي ده بقى شخص
تحط
الفكر الديني ده مع التوجه القومي ده
هتلاقي عندك مشكله كبيره جدا جدا لا
قادرين يحلوا مشكلتهم مع الفلسطينيين نعمل
ايه مع الفلسطينيين
ولا قادرين يحلوا مشكله الهويه هي دوله
دينيه يعني ينعم فيها اليهود ولا هي دوله
ديمقراطيه دي لها متطلبات ودي لها متطلبات
تانيه خالص
وبالمناسبه لما نعومه شمسكي مره قال عليهم
ان هم ليست حكومه فصل عنصري على اسرائيل
وسالوا لي ده اسوا لانه حكومه الفصل
العنصري اللي احنا التجربه الكتيره اللي
احنا شفناها اللي هي بتاعه جنوب افريقيا
قبل التسعينات كانت الحكومه البيضاء عاوزه
بتعاملهم على انه
السود او المواطن الاسود على انه درجه
تانيه وعاوزه تستغله بس تعتمد عليه تعتمد
عليه بشكل كبير يعني بتعطيه فرصه عمل
وتعامله وحش انما الاسرائيليين فيما يتعلق
بكثير من الفلسطينيين هي مش عاوزه تعتمد
عليهم هي عاوزه تعزلهم وتبعدهم وتتمنى لو
تتخلص منهم فهي اسوا
الاجابه المختصره انا طولت عليك يا ادريس
نعم الى حد كبير بس اسوا من اللي انت
بتقوله كمان مساء الخير استاذ سيد كل عام
وانتم بخير ربنا يخليك ويسعدك ويسعدك
نجم اهلا سيد جبيل اولا شكرا على المحتوى
الهادف ده اخونا
ام ام الديب يا ريت اكتبوا اساميكم الله
يخليكم في الاسئله بالعربي يعني الاسم
اللي تحب اندهلك به
وشكرا على المحتوى الهادف الجميل لرفع
الوعي العام سؤالي هل ترى مستقبل للعالم
العربي المغربي والمشرق في المستقبل
القريب هل تنصح بان يسعى الشباب الى
الهجره القانونيه
الجزء الاولاني من السؤال يعني
في يعني
في عشرات في مئات الملايين من العالم
العربي عايشين هنا يعني من المواطنين
افترض انه لازم يكون في مستقبل مستقبل جيد
اعتقد اه نفيب يبقى في فرصه ان اللي جاي
يكون احسن من اللي فات ده مش نوع من اعتقد
كده يعني انا شايف ان الامور
ليست بهذا السوء ولكن يعني ممكن ممكن اذا
ايقن الناس انه ما فيش حياه ومستقبل بدون
علم وبدون تعليم المساله كلها علم وتعليم
علم وتعليم علم وتعليم مش حاجه ثانيه
علمه تعليم وطبعا العلم والتعليم ده يتحول
طب العلم والتعليم ده يبدو ان موضوع بديهي
او انه موضوع ممل
اثناء الاضطرابات الاخيره في اسرائيل لما
طلعوا شركات الحي تك اللي هي بتمثل كما
اسمع يعني من 25 ما توقنتش من الرقم الى
30% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لاسرائيل
بياتي منين مش من التجاره ولا من التشهيد
والبناء بياتي من قطاع التكنولوجيا
المتطوره اللي اسرائيل سر تفوقها على
المنطقه وسر قدرتها على التفاوض مع الدول
الكبيره 25 الى 30% من الناتج المحلي
الاسرائيلي اللي هم حوالي 400 مليار دولار
يعني قد او اكبر شويه من الناتج المحلي
القومي لبلد زي مصر اللي فيها مش عارف كم
ضعف اسرائيل بقى 15 ضعف او اكتر
فبيقولوا لهم ايه بيقولوا لهم
الشركات دي لما خرجت في المظاهرات الاخيره
يا اما تلغوا هذه
التعديلات الدستوريه يا اما لن يكون هناك
تفوق تكنولوجي سوف نرحل عنكم
واذا رحلوا عنهم مش هيكون في تفوق
لاسرائيل تفوق الاسرائيلي النسبه مقارنه
بدول اخرى كثيره من العلم كل ما تسمعه عن
اجهزه المخابرات والجيش والطيران كله علم
في علم ليس اكثر من كده ناس عملت علم قدرت
بموجبه وتاخده من دول غيرها وهي تطوره هو
علم الزراعه وتحليه المياه واتقى النوويه
كل حاجه كل عباره عن علم سليم
لناس تعلمت كويس خدت فرصها بقت عندها فرصه
في الحياه واحنا بدون هذا العلم ملناش
طبعا مستقبل يعني هل تنصح برئاسه على
الشباب لا يعني دي حاجه ترجع يعني لظروف
كل واحد يعني اكيد مش ممكن هو حتى نصحته
او ما نصحتش مش معقوله بنتكلم كل مئات
الملايين دي هتهاجر هتهاجر فين اصلا ولكن
اللي الواحد يعني اذا كان ليا ان انا انصح
انه الناس بقدر الامكان كل الناس اللي هي
الشباب الصغير وغير الصغير انه يشتغل على
نفسه ويحسن من قدراته المهنيه
على امل ان يحسن فرصه في العمل داخل بلده
واذا ضيقت عليه الامور داخل بلده وعنده
فرصه بوسائل قانونيه يهاجر الى بلد افضل
وفقه الله
مساء الخير اتمنى بتمنى اعرف اذا قريت
رسائلي يلي بعثت لك على ماسنجر انا احمد
من سوريا
انا معلش احمد لو بس تقول لي الرساله مره
تانيه عن اي رساله تتحدث ما انا معك اهو
دلوقتي لو كتبت لي انا هرد عليك حالا
انا بس عاوز اقول لك ملحوظه صغيره انه
فيما يتعلق بالرسائل
يعني طبعا هو يعني
كتر خيركم ان بيجي لعدد رسائل كتير وهي
محل احترام وتقدير بس انا ما بيجيليش
رسائل مثلا على طريقه
الفنانين كده مثلا
انت مثلا ايه رايك في ما بتشاركش ليه في
قلوبهم والله اصل الفيلم مثلا مش لاقي ورق
حلو مثلا الورق الورق مش حلو اسئله عامه
كده او مثلا ايه رايك في اللون الازرق
فجميل الاسئله كله ناس عميقه زي حضراتكم
كده بتسال اسئله عميقه
فبيجي لي سؤال اه زي مندوب محتاجه
فالاسئله بتيجي برضو يعني
سؤال اجاوب عليه في قد ايه بتبقى اسئله ما
حد بياخد رايي في كتاب اذا كنت قريته فضلش
قريته ان حد بيسالني عن موضوع كبير عاوز
تحليل ونقاط واحد اتنين تلاته واربعه
فبيكون في صعوبه ببقى عاوز اتجاوب بس مش
عارف اقول ايه يعني يعني عاوز اقول له انا
حاضر هشوف طيب انا عاوز اجاوب ممكن يمكن
البث المباشر ده اسهل شويه ان انا اقول لك
اذا كنت اعرف الخص الفكره زي ما كنتش اعرف
اقول سامحني انا لا اعلم فيا ريت تكتب لي
دلوقتي وانا معاك احنا بنتقابل بمعدل مره
كل اسبوعين مش قليل يعني
كيف النظام الضريبي في الاسلام يعني ده
بقى عاوز رساله للدكتوراه لا اعلم هو مش
يعني هم عندهم الزكاه يعني في فكره
يعني الزكاه هي النظام الاساسي يعني
الزكاه او جهد انفاقها المختلف
وهذا ما اعلمه يعني
الضريبه بالمعنى
الحاله بالمعنى الحاليه يمكن ما اعرفش
العلماء المسلمين تجاوزوا مساله
الزكاه باوجهها المختلفه لكن في غيري
يعني عنده القدره انه يتناول المساله دي
بشكل ادق يعني
الازمه في اسرائيل علي من الجزائر انت لسه
داخل يا علي احنا اجبنا يا علي بس لو في
حاجه محدده انا تحت امرك
اتفاق البنك الدولي مع مصر هل هو بديل عن
دعم السعوديه والكويت
لا ما فيش بدائل ولا حاجه مصر محتاجه
الاتفاق مع البنك الدولي ومحتاجه الاتفاق
مع الصندوق النقد والاتنين دول مختلفين
لكنهم يعني يعني اولاد عم يعني الصندوق
بيحط برامج للاصلاح ويقرض والبنك الدولي
بيدفع قروض بفائده صغيره لاسباب تنمويه
يعني يقول لك مثلا انا ابني لك بنيه تحتيه
انا هحسن لك بعض القرى الصرف الصحي كده
يعني بس الاثنين لازم يشتغلوا هاند يعني
انما الاتنين دول لن يغنوا ابدا عن انه
بلد زي مصر او غير مصر تحصل على دعم بصور
مختلفه من كل الدول القادره على اعطاء
الدعم الدعم ده ممكن ياخد الصوره العاديه
ان انا بعمل عندك ودائع ان انا اعطيك
قروض انه
استثمر عندك
ويبقى هذا لا يغني عن ذاك
مساء العواف السيد احمد
الجبيل
انت اسمك السيد احمد الجبيل ولا لكن مساء
انت اسمك يوسف انا اسمي السيد جوبيل تصغير
الجبل اهلا وسهلا فانت اديتني احمد من
عندك كتر خيرك
هل اقفال الخلاف فات السياسيه فجاه وبسرعه
كبيره ان صح التعبير مثل ما حصل في صلح
دول الخليج مع قطر او في الصلح الصعود
الايراني هل هذه السرعه في حسم المفوضات
تعتبر ظاهره صحيه في العلاقات الدوليه لا
تعتبر ظاهره اذا كانت ظاهره يعني في
الشؤون الشرقة اوسطيه
انا بحاول افتكر كان لي صديق صحفي امريكي
والله اتمنى يكون بخير وبصحه لانه ما شاء
الله كان من جيل قريب من جيل الاستاذ هيكل
يعني هو في اواخر الثمانينيات
ما قابلتوش من 2011 انما وتواصلنا بعدها
عدد مش كبير من المرات صحفي
ومقدم برامج في عدد من قنوات الامريكيه
الكبيره يعني لو دورتم عليها هتلاقوه
انما فاكر افتكرته ليه لانه هو غطى احداث
كبيره من اللي احنا بالنسبه لنا تاريخ
يعني الثوره الايرانيه مثلا
حرب 73 احداث كثيره في المنطقه من الاحداث
المفصليه فلما كنت بساله من كم سنه
محترمين كده قبل ثورات الربيع العربي بقول
له ايه رايك في الاحداث والاحداث كانت
ساخنه والاجواء يعني كانت قال لي ما اقدرش
اقول لك رايي في حاجه لان الشرق الاوسط
شهير بانه لا يمكن التنبؤ باحداثه قلت له
ليه بقى قال لي احنا كنا موجودين بنغطي
احداث الجبهه في قبل 73 ولم نتوقع ابدا ان
مصر وسوريا تحارب اسرائيل
وكل موجودين في ايران هو كان موجود في قلب
ايران ولم نتوقع ابدا ان الثوره تندلع
ويتم الاطاحه بالشاه فدائما في مفاجات
وكلامه مش بس يعني صدق على المعدن البعيد
ده هو بعدها بشهور من كلامه ده قام
الثورات الربيع العربي اللي غيرت الدنيا
وما كانتش حد برضو شايفها بهذا الوضوح
فالشرق الاوسط في عمليه فيما كان في قوه
مهيمنه امبراطوريه حاكمه للمنطقه زي
الدوله العثمانيه او الدول بتمارس نفوس
مباشر زي الامبراطوريه البريطانيه او
الفرنسيه بحكم الاحتلال او بحكم الانتداب
او بحكم الحرب البارده يا الاتحاد
السوفيتي يا امريكا
الان الوضع ده مش موجود والدول دي بتحاول
ان هي تحل مشاكلها نفسها بنفسها فبيجربوا
بقى كل الوسائل جربوا المواجهه يعني
السعوديه وايران جربوا فرصه المواجهه
ونحارب بعض في اليمن جربوا وبعدين جربوا
المفاوضات وبعدين جربوا الحرب بالوكاله
وبعدين جاءوا المفاوضات وبيجربوا التقارب
تركيا كان عندها نفس الفكره انا عندي فرصه
وشايف انه امريكا بتضعف والاتحاد وروسيا
مش هتقدر والصين عازفه طب ادخل واتحرك في
هذا الفراغ وبعدين ادراكت بعد عشر سنوات
ان هي اجهدت جدا
واستنزفت ومضطر ان هي ترجع تاني لعلاقه
زيرو مشاكل مع دول الجوار الخلاصه انه
الصلح ما كانش سريع اولا ولكنه المساله
اللي انت ضربته بالسعوديه وتركيا
بالسعوديه وتركيا او السعوديه وايران ده
فكره مطروحه من فتره طويله جدا
انما هم ادراكا من الجميع انه وسائل
الخشنه ما جابتش نتيجه
ماذا يعني اصدار ده ولف ماذا يعني اصدار
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه قرار باعتقال
بوتين على رغم انه شيء مستحيل ان يتم
اعتقال رئيس دوله عظمى لكن ما المقصود
بذلك المقصود المضايقه
والمقصود التوتر والضغط النفسي وقد حدث
يعني النهارده يبقى بند من البنود اللي
بيعملها الخارجيه الروسيه انها تتاكد بشكل
سري او شكل علني انه اي سفر لبوتين لن
يتعرض للاعتقال ايوه مفهوم ان ده مش هيحصل
لانه ما حصلش حتى مع عمر حسن البشير في
السودان ولكن حاجه محرجه وتضغط على اي
مسؤول انه يدرك انه ممكن تتغير الظروف
ويجد نفسه ملاحق
هل انتهى السيسي وما هو مستقبل مصر
السياسي بعده لانتهى السيسي
وما مستقبل مصر السياسي بعده زي قبله يعني
كان فيه واحنا ما كناش نسمع عن الرئيس
مبارك قبل ما يختاروا الرئيس انور السادات
نائبا للرئيس كان احد يعني ضباط القوات
المسلحه ثم جاء واصبح رئيس مصر 30 سنه
الرئيس السيسي كان احد كبار الضباط في
القوات المسلحه وكان له زملاء كثيره وقبل
ان ياتي كانت مصر يعني موجوده وتعيش
ويحكمها رئيس وبعد ان يذهب الرئيس السيسي
سوف ياتي رئيس اخر وهكذا يعني فالمستقبل
موجود قبله وبعده اما حكايه الانتهاء ديت
فمش عارف ايه بتبني حساباتك على اي اساس
يعني
تحيه من متابعك اشرف من اين يجب ان تبدا
الديمقراطيه من تغيير النظام الحاكم من
جوده التعليم من حريه الصحافه من التوافق
الدولي ام من تجربه الخطا والصواب تريلان
يعني قصدك اين نقطه البدايه انا عاوز ارشح
لك كتاب مهم كتب الدكتور علي الدين هلال
هو اسمه مش موجود في ذهني بس هو عن يعني
لو كتبت كده عليه الدين هلال الدينوقراطيه
عليه الدين هلال ده احد كبار اساتذه النظم
السياسيه
لكن استاذ ماندو
درسنا كمان دول طيب
استاذ ماندو فهو الله يدي له الصحه
والعافيه وهو طبعا كان يعني
على العموم عشان ما نخرج شبرا الموضوع
انما هو له كتاب ممتاز جدا عن الديمقراطيه
ووجه الامتياز ان هو عرض فكره الاجابه
عليها صعبه ليه شعوب بتقدر توصل
للديمقراطيه وشعوب ما بتقدرش
فالكتاب والكتاب ما هواش كبير ومتاح على
ديجيتال يعني فهتستمتع به انما الاجابه
موضوع الديمقراطيه ده نحددها الاول لان كل
شعوب العالم بتقول انا ديمقراطي بما فيها
حتى كوريا الشماليه بتقول انا دوله
ديمقراطيه يعني
انما الديمقراطيه اللي في ذهنك بتتحقق لما
بتكون في اراده والاراده ديت بتيجي من
جميع الاطراف او من طرف بيدخل في صراع مع
اطراف اخرى ورحله المعاناه ديت بين
الاطراف المختلفه هي اللي بتقنع الناس انه
ما فيش وسيله لبلد
بتعيش فيه فئه مختلفه اديان مختلفه اعراق
مختلفه الا نظام بتقوم فيه فكره سياده
القانون وان سياده القانون ده بيقول انا
مش فارق معايا مسلم ولا مسيحي ولا يهودي
رجل او سيده ابيض ولا اسود انا هعمل ده هل
ده بيتم في المطلق لا مش في المطلق لانه
ما انت عندك امريكا اللي هي دوله
ديمقراطيه كبيره مثلا السود بيعانوا من
تمييز عنصري نسبي بس مش ممنهج مش الدوله
بتقول لا للسود او لا للصينيين انما
ممارسات شخصيه يعاقب صاحبها انضبط بممارسه
العنصريه ده بيتم
بالوقت يعني البريطانيا خدت صوت كبير جدا
فرنسا اخذت شوت ايطاليا علشان تتوحد خدوا
شوط كبير واحنا كمان هناخذ شوط كبير
واتمنى يا رب تكون احنا بس نبدا فيه الاول
الدهب هيزيد بعد التعويم
ما بديش اجابات ما هو لازم يزيد اذا كنت
كلمه التعلم على مصر انت لما تيجي تتكلم
على انه عمله محليه هتنخفض هتنخفض مقابل
ايه هتنخفض مقابل الدولار يبقى كل السلعه
اللي مقاومه بالدولار طبيعي ان هي حتى لو
ما ارتفعتش في العالم هترتفع في الدول دي
يعني لو كان مثلا جرام الذهب بيساوي انا
بقول اي كلام يعني 100 دولار والميه دولار
دول بيساوي
3000 جنيه مصري
فجاه المساله زادت بقى الميه دولار يعني
كده الجرام بيساوي 3000 جنيه مصري طيب لو
الميه جرام لو الميه دولار بقت تساوي 6000
لا قدر الله يعني يبقى اكيد الجرام هيبقى
ب 6000 جنيه مصري من غير ما يزيد في
العالم
فاي بلد هتنخفض عملته كل السلع المقاومه
بالدولار هتزيد او المستورده من دول اخرى
خارجيه يعني
ويا ريت لو انتم عاوزين تستثمروا في حكايه
الحاجات اللي هي السلعه دي العقارات
والذهب انك بس تستشير حد يكون فاهم يعني
مش في المطلق كده في احيانا تروح تشتري
الذهب تشتريه في الوقت اللي هو مرتفع فيه
جدا وتيجي تبيعه وتبيعه في الوقت اللي هو
منخفض فيه جدا فاستعين بمن يفهم حتى لو
هتدفع له فلوس بس تستعين وتفهم علشان ما
تروحش انت من نفسك كده روح اشتروا فتبقوا
ضحايا تبقوا ضحايا لتجار الدهب انا كنت
بقول لزمايلي في احد البرامج الاقتصاديه
في احد القنوات يعني بيسالوني
استشاره يعني كده فبقول لهم رجاء انتم كل
ما بتستعينوا بحد من اللي بيجي يتكلم على
الذهب من ساعه ما انا طفل كل ما تجيب واحد
يقول لك اشتري الذهب اشتري الذهب عمره ما
ينخفض قل لهم كل دول عباره عن يا تجار يا
لهم مصلحه في الذهب والاجابه الوحيده عنده
كل ما تساله عن حركه الذهب بينصحك بالشراء
لانه مصلحته ان انت تشتري فاسمع وفكر هو
مصلحته ايه ممكن مال وش مصلحه انه ياخذ
منك هو عاوز السوق كله يكون في الصاعد
عشان البضاعه اللي عنده ترتفع يقوم بعديهم
فشوف اللي بيدي النصيحه ده هو موقفه منها
ايه واسال حد بتثق فيه او اكتر من حد
وبعدين خد قرارك
عندي سؤال يخص الانتخابات الامريكيه هل
تتوقع فوز ترامب
ايرلي يا صديقي من المبكر يا صديقي المبكر
يعني ده ترامبولش الانتخابات اصلا معقولها
الملاحقات دي وبعدين الراجل ده
والله احنا افتقدناك الراجل ده خفيف قوي
يعني
مشاكله مشاكل عجيبه غريبه يعني نسمع عن
رئيس امريكي كان مثلا كان مش عارف يعني
عمل مثلا حاجه كده
قالوا ان عنده ابن مكان من علاقه غير
شرعيه لا اصله هو
كان تورط فيه انه مثلا دعم حرب ثم انتقدها
عنده سجل لكن درجه عنده ايه كل المشاكل
تهرب ضريبي علاقات مع عاهرات
زلت لسان سخريه وتنمر من مثلا من
من بشر معينين من فئه معينه
ومع ذلك عنده اكتر من 70 مليون ولا 75
مليون انتخبوه
ما ده وضع امريكا زي وضع اسرائيل في مشاكل
عميقه تتجاوز ترامب وتتجاوز بيضا انه في
عشرات الملايين في امريكا حسينا ان هم مش
مستفيدين من السياسات اللي اتابعتها من
ستريم الطبقه اللي كانت قبل ترامبو اللي
بعد ترامب فشافوا فالراجل ده بيقول لهم
ناس دول نصابين وتعالوا معي انا ممكن
اساعدكم
رمضان مبارك من الجزائر استاذ انت تتحدث
عن الازمه بين الجزائر والمغرب وكيف
تجاوزها هو احنا تحدثنا اخونا يوسف كثيرا
عن الجزائر والمغرب
كيف كيفيه تجاوزها لا هم مش مستنيين ان
انا اقول لهم كيف يتجاوزها اصل في ناس
مستفيدين اصلا من الخلافات يعني مش هي
حاجه مش الازمات بتبقى موجوده لانه اصحاب
الازمات مش عارفين ايه طبيعه الازمه وازاي
تجاوزها الازمات بتبقى موجوده لانه اولا
في تناقضات يعني اللي يبسطك ينكد عليا ما
هو منفعه لك هو خساره لي
لانه في حاله قلق اللي هو مبدا توازن
القوه ان كل اي دولتين متنافستان
كل ما يصب في مصلحه هذه الدوله يقلق هذه
الدوله وبالتالي يبقى في عدم ثقه وقلق
وترقب
تلاته ان في ناس مستفيده دايما من الصراع
اولا انا ما بتكلمش على الجزائر والمغرب
بس الجزائر والمغرب وغيرهم بتبقى في نخاب
حاكمه مستفيده دايما من وجود عدو خارجي
تعلق على شماعته كل الاضطرابات وكل
المشاكل الداخليه
تشتت برضو انتباه الناس شويه
مستفيدين يعني
لكن عموما حتى يعني اجيب حضرتك هو لو بحثت
باسم كلمه الجزائر او المغرب هتلاقي حوالي
ثلاث او اربع حلقات استاذنك شاهدهم واذا
كان لديك سؤال محدد في هذه المساله يسعدني
ان كنت اعرف ان اجيبك استاذ سيد ممكن
احنا كنا فين
ما هي اخر التطورات في الصراع الاسرائيلي
الايراني لا ما فيش تطورات الصراع
الاسرائيلي الايراني حتى الان
يسير كما هو ايران مصره ان هي تذهب الى
ابعد مدى عند
عتبه القدره النوويه وقد وصلت يعني تبقى
في اي وقت قادر على تصنيع السلاح النووي
قادره على تسليح نفسها بشكل يجعل من هجوم
عليها من اسرائيل او امريكا مخاطره يجب ان
يحسبوا حسابها مئات المرات وهم يحسبون هذا
الحساب على مدار 20 سنه على الاقل
وخائفين من الاقبال على هذه الخطوه
ومصر على ان هي تقترب بقوتها
وحلفائها ومليشياتها الى حدود اسرائيل وهي
تفعل ذلك بدرجات مختلفه من النجاح
واسرائيل مصره على ان هي تهاجم كل هؤلاء
الميليشيات بدرجات احيانا تنجح واحيانا
تفشل
يعني تحشد كل حلفاء في الغرب وعلى راسهم
امريكا للضغط على ايران وهي بتنجح بدرجات
مختلفه
هي مصره على اجراء عمليات تخريب للبرنامج
النووي والضغط على
والاختراق في الداخل الايراني وبتعمل ده
بدرجات نجاح احيانا بتبقى كويسه جدا
واحيانا فاشله ايران بترد بعمليات ما حدش
بيعرف عنها كتير لكن عرفنا مثلا ان كان
طباخ وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي الماضي ضبط
وهو يتجسس لصالح ايران فالعمليه واحده
بواحده واللي بيمنع الاتنين من ان هم يبقى
في مواجهه عنيفه انه عارفين ان التكلفه
عاليه جدا جدا جدا
ما هي اهداف كامله حرس اللي هي نائبه وزير
نائبه رئيس امريكا
لغانا وكيف ستمكن الغرب من السعاده ثقه
الجنوب العالمي هدف انت اجبت على السؤال
ده ايزو
[موسيقى]
الهدف هي الصراع على موارد افريقيا وعلى
ثروات افريقيا وعلى يعني اصوات افريقيا في
الامم المتحده
والصراع ده امريكا حست ان هي استهنت
بافريقيا كثيرا
فتسللت الصين على مدار العشرين 30 سنه
اللي فاتت واصبحت هي اكبر شريك تجاري لكل
افريقيا كما هي الشريك الاكبر لكل دول
العالم ثم تسللت روسيا واصبحت بائع سلاح
رئيسي واصبحت شريك امني من خلال فاجنر او
غير فاجنر واصبحت شريك في كثير من
المشروعات اللي موجوده في افريقيا وادركت
امريكا انه نصيبها بيتراجع في هذه القاره
الغنيه في العالم اللي هي مهمه بسبب
اصواتها في الامم المتحده 54 دوله وبسبب
ثرواتها الضخمه اللي هي مواد اساسيه في
الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه والخامسه
واسواقها الكبيره بنتكلم على مئات
الملايين من البشر اللي عاوزين ياكلوا
ويشربوا ومحتاجين واردات امريكا تفضل ان
شركات هي اللي توفرهم هو ده الهدف ليس
اكثر ولا اقل
مساء الخير استاذ سيد المحترم الله يخليك
يا محمد جندي محمد هل مصر تحت وصيه البنك
الدولي لا يا محمد مش تحت وصيه البنك
الدولي
ياسر السيد ممكن تجاوب بطريقه مباشره
اهلاوي ولا زملكاوي زملكاوي ياسر انبسطت
كده
[ضحك]
انا كمان عضو في النادي يعني مش بس لكن
انا والله بريء من اللي انت في ذهنك اذا
كنت بتتكلم على ممارسات هذا الشخص فانا
بريء منه يعني انا انا بتكلم على نادي
الزمالك اللي احنا حبيناه يعني كنادي مش
بس عشان الكوره ولكن في رياضات تانيه
كتيره بس يعني
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته الله
يخليك ارشيلي كل احترامي وتقديري مساء
الخير استاذنا
ربنا يخليك ويسعدك هل تمر العلاقات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه مرحله حارجه ما
تقلقش على الاسرائيليين حاجه مش حرجه
دايما عندكم دلاله على على الامريكان ده
اخونا هانز زمر متقلقش عليهم مرحله حرجه
ايه ده
اسرائيل في اسوا احوالها وفي اسوا بغياها
وغيها بتجد من يدافع عنها
لكن اه يعني زي المرحله الحرجه اللي مرت
بها اثناء اوباما
ماذا على فكره في ملحوظه صغيره بس ده
موضوع ممكن يبقى اللي بتتكلم عن ضروره
التفاوض مع الفلسطينيين اللي بتتكلم تقول
انا دوله ديمقراطيه يتساوى فيها الجميع
اللي ما بتتكلمش على دوله دينيه اللي
بتتكلم على اسرائيل العلمانيه اللي بتتكلم
على وضع حاله مثاليه سواء تحققت قبل لم
تتحقق لكن ده اللي في ذهنهم يعني هو ده
اللي كان بيغريهم في التجربه الاسرائيليه
للدفاع عنها مش هو ده يعني ده جزء من
التجربه اللي بتخليهم يدافعوا عنها ويبقوا
مطمئنين يعني كده قدام ضمائرهم انما
اسرائيل دوله دينيه وقوميه
وناس بتقول تصريحات مستفزه وعايزين يدخلوا
في حرب مع الجميع بسبب قراءتهم لكتب
التوراه يعني طبعا كثير من الامريكان
اليهود انفسهم لن يكونوا سعداء بذلك
وزي ما كان بيقول واحد من زعماء اللوبي
اليهودي لم اكن اتخيل ابدا ان اقول ان
دعمي لاسرائيل اسقندشن مشروط مشروط بان هي
ترجع للمسار السليم كنت دائما اقول والائي
ودعم لاسرائيل انكونديشنل بلا شرط ولا قيد
اليوم
ما مستقبل الحرب في اليمن الوحده والتقسيم
وما مصير حضرموت والمهر شوف الاجابه
العامه لا اتصور ابدا قدره اليابانيين ولا
رغبه الدول الكوار في ان تكون هناك اياما
موحده اذا حدث ذلك سوف تكون معجزه من
معجزات الله
وقس عليه بقى اذا كان في اي بقى اماكن
يبقى لها وضع خاصيه لتشير اليها انما لا
استطيع ان اتخيل
ان تعود اليمن دوله واحده ولا ان في كتير
من الناس اصلا غير سعيد بذلك ولا منطقيا
على الارض ممكن ده يتحقق ما لم تكن لله
مشيئه اخرى لعشرات السنين القادمه
اليوم تم تعيين خالد بن محمد بن زايد ولي
العهد بالامارات رايك في ذلك ليس لي رايه
فهد محتاج ان انا يعني
افهم المساله اكثر لكن ليس لي راي يعني
على الحاضر في ذهني
لما المحيط العربي خارج الجزيره السعوديه
انا اصلا معرفش هذا الخبر لما اقراه اليوم
يعني فانا شاكر ان انت لفت نظري لشيء
اشكرك
لما المحيط العربي خارج الجزيره السعوديه
يحمل الكراهيه لماذا اكيد لماذا دي لماذا
المحيط العربي خارج الجزيره يحمل الكراهيه
اتجاه السعوديه انا ما عملتش استطلاعات
راي
يا اخونا ام حاجه
انا ما عملتش استطلاعات رايي وما اعتقدش
ان عندك استطلاعات رايه بتقول انه المحيط
والمحيط ده ايه يعني ايران تركيا ولا
الدول الخليج ولا الدول العربيه ولا
العالم الاسلامي حدد السؤال علشان ما
نعملش اجابه فيها تعميم غير مناسب انما هي
اللي انا اللي انا جازم بيه وانا فاكر ان
انا مره كنت
مش عارف يمكن تكون مش مناسبه شويه ولكن هي
كانت جلسه فيها عدد من الدبلوماسيين
والمفكرين وهكذا يعني
ومنهم يعني في احد البلاد الخليجيه لكن هي
كانت باختصار يعني لان انا يعني بقول بلاش
لانه تحدثوا كان قعده يعني خارج التسجيل
انما قتل الخلاصه ان في بعض الناس اللي هم
تعلموا تعليما راقيا في الفتره مبكره سواء
في دول الشام في مصر لبنان دول الى اخره
يعني دول المغرب العربي اخرين
كانوا مستائين تحديدا لانه السعوديه
لسنوات طويله دعمت اتجاهين
دعمت محاربه تيار القوميه العربيه بقياده
جمال عبد الناصر اللي كان بيمثل امل لدول
كثيره واللي كان بيمثل مقاومه لفكره
السيطره من من الغرب المحتل توافق ما
توافقش بس السعوديه دعم ده ودعمت ده
الاسباب مفهومه هو كان عاوز يسقط الملكيات
وبعدين السعوديه ملكيه فبتقول له انا
مصيري ايه ما انت كده عاوز تسقطني انا
كمان
الحاجه التانيه ان هي دعمت فكره تصدير
الوهابيه ودلوقتي السعوديين بيتكلموا عن
الوهابيه بس انا فاكر ان القناه دي اول ما
طلعت في
يعني من كم سنه كده بتاع سبع سنين ولا
حاجه كان بيجي لي رود فعلا غاضبه لما
استخدم كلمه الوهابيه وبيعتبروا ان ده
مجرد تقول الوهابيه احنا مش وهابيين احنا
مسلمين ومحمد
ومحمد بن عبد الوهاب لم ياتي بدين جديد
يعني كانوا حساسين لي المساله طرحه من
الاساس دلوقتي بقت مطروحه انما كان حساسيه
من كبار المثقفين والنخب في الدول العربيه
محيطه من اصرار السعوديه على الاستثمار في
هذا التيار الديني الاتنين دول كانوا
بيعتبروا ضرب القوميه العربيه
توافق ترفض انا بقول لك يعني ده اللي حصل
وفكره تصدير الوهابيه للعالم الخارجي اللي
هي مرتبطه في اذهان كتير من النخب بانها
مرادف لي يعني مش عاوز استخدم الكلمه
القاسيه يعني لكن هكذا راوها انها مرادف
للتخلف معاداته للعلم معاه للتطور فكانوا
بيشوفوا في السعوديه هذه المساله الامور
بتتغير الان الامور تغيرت في الدول اللي
كانت بترا كده وتتغير في السعوديه الان
وبالتالي
ما اعتقدش ان الطيار ده بقى موجود قوي
والتيار اللي موجود هو التيار العادي اذا
كان في تيار اصلا هو اللي شايف اللي
مصالحه مع السعوديه بيدعمها واللي
بيصالحوا ضدها
بكل موقف مختلف بس النظره لدول الخليج
كلها اختلفت كتير كتير كتير عن سنوات
الخمسينات والستينات والسبعينات
احمد محمد استثنى الفاضل انا بحبك كتير
بتمنى بس اعرف اذا بتقرا رسائل الماسنجر
انا بعرف انك تكون مشغول بس هل رسائل من
كذا شهر
وحابب اعرف اذا على الاقل ما انا مش عارف
انهي رساله بتشير اليها يا احمد انا لسه
اعتقد انت بعت رساله وانا يمكن جاوبتك مش
احمد
يعني انا انا بشوف رسايل طبعا في رسائل
بتعدي لكن بشوف رسايل
وعدد كبير من الرسايل وبرد على عدد كبير
من الرسائل بس انا بقول هي فكره انه
احيانا بتيجي الرساله ما فيش فيها اه ولا
لا مش حد مثلا بيقول لي مساء الخير فانا
ما بردش او بيسال استفسار بسيط فانا بشير
اليه انما هي مثلا بيقول لي انا هبعت لك
الكتاب قل لي رايك فيه فبيبقى مثلا
انا حريص اعمل ده بس انا عندي كل اسبوع
عدد كبير من الالتزامات تجاه سواء
البرنامج هنا او نعرف اقتصاد او شغل الاخر
فبيكون فيه صعوبه بقدر ما انا راغب اعمل
ده ولكن
احيانا بكون عاجز ان انا اعمله
لكن انا برد على رسايل كثيره وفي ناس
بعتولي حل مثلا انتاج محتوى قولي له يقول
لي رايك فيه وابديت رايي المتواضع فيه كتر
خيرهم يعني انهم عاوزين يعرفوا رايي في
ناس بعثوا لي سالوني عن حاجات كثيره لكن
الحاجات اللي بتستغرق وقت كتير وخصوصا لو
انا ما اعرفهاش يعني بيقول لي رايك في
كتاب ممكن انا ما اعرفوش اصلا
بقول له لم اقراه يعني فاحيانا يبعت لي
كتاب يقول انا عاوز اعرف رايك في دم فيعني
لكن انا حريص والله
والافضل ان انت تتواصل معي ابعت الرسائل
بس برضو التواصل معي كده لان انا ممكن
اجاوب هنا في دقيقه دقيقتين بس عشان
اكتبها كده ممكن خصوص انا بكتب بقى على ده
ممكن اقعد اليوم كله ههه اكتب فيه يعني
استاذ الوضع السوري وتعويم بشار الاسد ما
رايك بما يجري التعويم يعني انقاذ بشار
الاسد لا هو اللي بيحصل انه ما حدش عاوز
ينقذ بشار الاسد في ناس عاوزين ينقذوا
انفسهم
اللي حاصل ودي نقطه مهمه جدا انه
دول كان في تيار سائد بعد 2011 واندلاع
الحرب الاهليه وانا مصر اسميها بالحرب
الاهليه
مش عاوز تسميها بالحرب الاهليه خلاص ما
تزعلوش سميها كما تشاء كل الاحترام لان
المساله دي مساله بالغه الحساسيه لكثير من
السوريين اللي اوذوا من هذه الحرب سواء
كانوا مع الرئيس بشار او جدتهم
ما حدث في سوريا كان في طيار قوي بعد 2011
هذا التيار هو ضروره اسقاط بشار الاسد وكل
والطيار ده اللي تزعمته دول الخليج قطر
والسعوديه والامارات
كانوا يروا انه يعني صعب انه بشار الاسد
يكمل هم ما كانش حابينه الاول من
سنوات سبقت لكن كانوا مش متخيلين انه ممكن
يتخلصوا منه مش حابينه ليه قصه طويله ولكن
هم شايفينه ان هو على علاقه قويه جدا
بايران اللي هي الخطر الاساسي عليهم
شايفين ان السياساته في لبنان ولبنان دوله
حليفه لدول الخليج بتضرهم وهم لهم مصالح
كتيره في لبنان
ابسطها مصالحهم الاستثماريه وفنادئهم
وتلاتهم
الاماكن اللي كانوا بيقضوا فيها يعني
مصايفهم وسياحتهم يعني واسباب سياسيه
واسباب استراتيجيه يعني
قام اقتل رفيق الحريري 2005 وهم اتهموه
بقتل رفيق الحريري وتوترت العلاقه يعني
الخلاصه ان هو ما كانش يعني ما كانش صديق
لهم زي مبارك مثلا
جاءت ثورات جاءت الاحداث بتاعه 2011 بتنقم
من مارس 2011 وهو كمان بالغ جدا جدا في
استخدام القوه والاعلام صلت كثير لان كان
في دول من الاول عاوزه تخلص منه فكل ما تم
ظهر على الشاشه وبعده تم المبالغه فيه
والصور الشهيره ديت تقول ان ربك بشار
الاسد انا مش عارف اذا كان الكلام ده صحيح
ولا لا ولكن صوره زي كده نجيب واحد بيضرب
واحد ويقول له قول ان ربه الكلام ده عمل
تاثير كبير جدا في الشارع والمساله خدت
بعد طائفي انه واحد علوي وواحد شيعي بيضرب
واحد سني في الشارع بقى حصلت له عمليه
تجهيش
الانظمه وجدت نفسها تحت ضغط هم مش حابينه
هو صديق لايران وحليف ليها في ضغط
موجود من الشارع اللي موجود في دول الخليج
او غير دول الخليج كل ده خلاهم قطعوا
العلاقات معه وكان وجهه نظرهم نسقتهم
كانوا معتقدين ان ده يحصل ما حصلش تدخلت
ايران تدخلت روسيا واذا كانت دول الخليج
كانت مستعده لدعم الطيارات
المعارضه لي بمليارات فائران وروسيا
استثماره مش بس مليارات استثمروا مليارات
وارواح جاؤوا بجنود على الارض الخليج دعمه
جامعات دول دعموا جامعات وجاو بجيوشهم
فالنتيجه انه بقى فبقى في تيار بدا يظهر
قادته الامارات اللي كانت اعلى صوتا من
2018 مع البحرين قالت مش هينفع الكلام ده
احنا لازم بقى ايه
نقرب الامر الواقع وبدا الطيار ده يصعد في
الفتره الاخيره
وجت السعوديه في حوالي اسبوعين وقالت
والله احنا هنفتح قنصليات واعلنوا كده
بشكل عاجل في
من كان من حوالي اسبوعين ان احنا يعني
ممكن ايه نعيد فتح القنصليه المفاوضات
جاريه والمفاوضات دي فيها مجموعه من
المطالب المطلب الاول راعي مصالحنا يعني
مش طول الوقت انت مع ايران احنا عندنا
مصالح اثنين هدي الاوضاع ما انت علشان
احنا هنتصالح معك ما انت لازم تتفاهم مع
المعارضه مش هينفع فكره انه
في قضايا امنيه لازم نتفاهم عليها منها
الكبتاجون ده ولا اسمه ايه اللي هو المخدر
ده اللي غزا الاسواق العربيه وجاي من عندك
ففي مجموعه من الشروط وهو عنده شروط
خلوا الضغط العنيف اللي موجود علي في
قنواتكم وحكايه نظام بشار وقولوا الحكومه
السوريه ارجع لمقعدي عافيه في جامعه الدول
العربيه تبداوا في
اوت تنقذوني انا عندي اقتصادي بيغرق انا
مش هفضل كده كتير
فالشروط ديت دائره بس الشروط دي عوده بشار
الاسد الدول العربيه هتاخد اجراءات كويس
بس بدون موافقه امريكا واوروبا لان دول
فردين عقوبات فالنهارده تيجي الشركات
الاماراتيه او السعوديه تيجي تستثمر فتفرد
عليها عقوبات فهتبقى استثمرت في سوريا
وده حاجه كويسه وفي نفس الوقت حرمت من
دخول السوق الاوروبي او من امريكا هتبقى
مشكله كبيره فعمليه عاوزه تفاهم
على مستوى اكبر
لازم برضو اسرائيل كلها دور اذا اسرائيل
ما لهاش دور هتبقى فيها مشكله
هل ترى ان الازمه ده رضوان بين الجزائر
والمغرب قد تصل الى حرب لا ارى ذلك وبرضو
مره تانيه في عده حلقات عن هذا الموضوع
والسبب لو كانت الحرب وارده لندلعت منذ
فتره ولكن الحرب صعبه لا تندلع لسببين في
توازن في القوه اولا اثنين ما فيش ازمه
عنيفه الى درجه تصل الى الحرب ثانيا
وثالثا ماذا يمكن ان تحقق اي عمليه عسكريه
الجهات السياسيه لما بتصدر للجنرال امر
بالحرب بيكلفه بمهمه محدده ايه هي المهمه
اللي ممكن يتكلف بها جنرال تحل المشكله في
توتر بين دولتين هتحله بايه يعني بانك
يعني تستعيد مثلا في ارض حدوديه انت مختلف
عليها مثلا
مش عارف ليه يبقى في حرب يعني
هل يوجد لاسرائيل نوايا الاحتلال الاردن
اسرائيل لو عليها
لا الاجابه لا يعني علشان ما اقولش كلام
ما اعرفش ان في اي نوايا الاحتلال الاردن
وتبقى خطوه غبيه وخطوه مش مفهومه
كلام مش معقول يعني كلام عبسي
وتفتح على نفسها تدخل في بلد في تسعه عشره
مليون تعمل ايه يعني كلام مش منطقي يعني
اذا لا قدر الله فعل ذلك هتكون عمل زي حد
بيحاول انه يعني
يبتلع اكثر مما يستطيع ان ينضغ
السيد المحترم هل تعتقد ان السيسي تترشح
لعهده جديده نعم اعتقد ذلك سلامات استاذ
سيد ده عمر الله يسلمك
عبد الرحمن هل الصوت من عندك واحنا نتحكم
بالصوت من عندنا انا نعليه بس الصوت
فعلا ضعيف
استاذنك علي الصوت هل يا شباب الصوت عند
الكل ضعيف انت بس عندك انت يا اخونا عبد
الرحمن
صح كده يا ماندو اتكلم بثقه يا ماندو ضع
نفسك مكان الدول الغربيه هم اولا لا يثقوا
في بوتين ولا في نظام حكمه اللي هو نظام
يقوم بنظام بيسموه
كلمه وحط لها تبقى نظام غير راضي عن
اوضاعه ويعتقد ان ما وصلت اليه روسيا في
علاقتها بالغرب بان هي تنشر قواعد عسكريه
بانها تمنع بلد زي اوكرانيا من الانضمام
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي ولو بالقوه
بعمليه
اختراقات فهم حاسين ان في بلد ضخم كبير
بلد يعني
كما يحب ان يصف نفسه اكبر قوه نوويه مش
هتفرق اكبر قوه نوويه لتاني اكبر قوه
نوويه ويقدر يدمر العالم والسلام
وانه قلقانين ان حتى اذا انت خدت النهارده
اوكرانيا وسيبناها لك هتقول لي انا عاوز
بولندا انا عاوز دول البلطيق التلاته
في تناقضات عنيفه ما فيش ثقه وده مشكله
كبيره لانه كل ما تفعله روسيا بيثير قلق
الغرب وكل ما يفعله الغرب بيثير قلق روسيا
وخصوصا في الدول اللي هي على الحدود مع
الروس وبالتالي هم شايفين انه امى وقد
اندلعت الحرب اما وان كتير من الامور اللي
كانوا مش متخيلينها حدثت يبقى الافضل اللي
هي تخرج روسيا سالمه من هذه الحرب والا
تخرج منتصره علشان ما يشجعاش انتصاره على
تكرار التجربه مع اخرين
ذكرت سابقا
ده اخونا ايزو
وتشاد خدوا
ماشي يا اخوان وكثر خيرك ذكرت سابقا استاذ
سيد النبي بريطانيه خسرت قدرتها على ان
تصبح قوه عظمى استاذنك ان توضح لنا ما هي
الاشياء التي خسرتها خسرت كتير
دي كانت الامبراطوريه التي لا تغرب عنها
الشمس يعني لما تكون في وقت من الاوقات هي
بتسيطر على الهند التاريخيه يعني الهند
اللي هي الهند اللي هي موجوده ديت وشبه
القاره الهنديه كلها ومعها باكستان ومعها
بنجلاديش ومعها دول اخرى
كانت ضمن مستعمراتها ومعها معظم دول الشرق
الاوسط ومعها كثير من دول افريقيا لما كل
الدول دي تنسلخ واحده بعد الاخرى
فتصبح بريطانيا بلا مستعمرات الا
جزر صغيره في البحر الهادي ولا في المحيط
الهادي او غيره يعني او
ولما تبقى جزء من الاتحاد الاوروبي وتبقى
خبمه الشريك الاكبر كتله الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لها 15 16 تريليون دولار ثم تصبح
خارج هذا الاتحاد
وبالتالي بريطانيا خسرت كثير خسرت كثير
يعني اصبحت دوله من الميديم سايز او
الاقتصادات
ولذلك هي فقدت وبعدين هي فين انت لما تيجي
تدور على اكبر الشركات في العالم مش
هتجدها شركه بريطانيه اهم الجامعات الكبرى
في العالم هتلاقي نصيب بريطانيا نصيب مش
كبير منها لما هتتكلم على النهارده كان
فيه من شهر التقارير بتاعه وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه تقول ان احنا اذا دخلنا حرب
كبيره جيشنا لا يستطيع ان يصمت بامكانيات
الحاليه اكثر من خمسه ايام
قدرتك على حاجات كتيره مش موجوده فطبيعي
ان بريطانيا يتراجعت وتراجعت وتراجعت
شكرا يا احمد شكرا يا صديقي هل الاوضاع في
فرنسا وغيرها من الدول المتعلقه بما يحدث
في اوكرانيا ولا في اسباب اخرى ده اسلام
لو بتتكلم عن المظاهرات لا العلاقه يعني
هو في قلق في فرنسا
طبعا يعني في علاقه بس عاوز اقول لك ان في
حاجات لها اسباب مثلا لاسباب ما حدش كتير
بيناقشها يعني انت بتتكلم الخلاف اللي
موجود ايه قانون التقاعد هم عايزين يخلوا
التقاعد بدل سن 62 يخلوه 64
يعني بدل ما تطلع معاش على عندك انت 62
سنه يبقى 64 سنه طبعا ده تغير كبير قوي
لانه انا فاكر من من 15 عشرين يمكن اكتر
شويه سنه كان في اتجاه في هذه الدول ان هم
يقللوا عدد ساعات العمل ما يبقاش اربعين
ساعه مثلا خلوه اظن خمسه وتلاتين او اقل
عشان الناس تستمتع بحياتها ده ايام متران
انما في تغيرات كبيره من بين التغيرات ديت
احنا كنا لسه بنتكلم على بريطانيا ان هذه
الدول بتفقد نفوذها في الدول اللي كانت
عايشه عليها يعني فرنسا بتفقد كتير من
الدول اللي لها نفوس كان عليها في افريقيا
وعايشه هي عليها على ثرواتها اللي هي
بتاخدها منها
يعني نفوذها القديم عليها
مش عاوز اقول يعني
بتسرقها يعني ولكن كانت عايشه هي بتضعف
نفوذها في الدول الافريقيه زي بريطانيا في
دول اخرى في العالم فبتضعف تنجح جدا
تغير الديموغرافي ده ادى حاجه منه ايجابيه
وحاجه سلبيه الحاجه الايجابيه ان الناس
اعمارها زادت الاحصاءات في فرنسا والدول
الاوروبيه ديت بتقول ان متوسط عمر الواحد
بعد المعاش 25 سنه كامله 25 سنه ده كان
متوسط عمر الانسان في القرون الوسطى ناس
كانت بتموت ايه 20 25 30 كده يعني
دلوقتي بعد ما بيطلع معاش 62 سنه بيعيش في
المتوسط 25 سنه جيد ده جيد بس بس اللي مش
جيد ان هو محتاج بقى انه ياخد معاش
طويل الامد يبقى لازم الدوله تتفاعلوا هو
اشتغل 25 سنه او 30 سنه عاوز الدوله تدفع
له 25 سنه تاني ده ما كانش الحسبه
الاكتواريه معموله كده لما اتعملت
او صناديق المعاش طب عشان يعوضها لازم
يكون في قوه عامله جديده بتدخل السوق ما
فيش قوه عاملها بتدخل السوق بنفس القدر
لانه الناس مش عاوزه تخلف وعدد السكان عدد
السن بيكبر مش بيصغر الناس عاوزه في اتجاه
لعدم الانجاب والعدم الخلفه وعدم قبول
المهاجرين فالنتيجه انه في تغيرات غريبه
الشكل في اوروبا لسه كان حد كاتب مش فاكر
اسمه
بيقول انه انا لاحظت في شهر واحد قريت
ثلاث اخبار الخبر اللي انا بكلمكم عليه
دوت اللي هو بقى له كتير الاضطرابات في
فرنسا
وخبر انه في احد الولايات الامريكيه اظن
اركانسيس ولا
اذا كان انا فاكر يعني انه بيحاولوا
يغيروا القوانين بحيث يسمحوا بالعماله تحت
16 سنه وانه في في ايطاليا توسع في
استخدام الروابط للعنايه بكبار السن اللي
هم حوالي سبعه مليون من ستين مليون ايطالي
وهو شايف ان القسم المشترك هي فكره اللي
هي الفكره دي انه اعمار بتزيد عدد الكبار
الغير قادرين على الانتاج بيزيد راغبين في
انه يعيشوا بنفس الراهيل اللي عاشوا عليها
لكن ما فيش قوه شابه بتدخل العمل لانه ما
فيش مهاجرين بيمنعوهم او مش حابين ان
يتمسعوا معاهم وفي نفس الوقت لا يريد
الانجاب وفي خلل ديموغرافي
ياثر على المساله انت بقى بتقول لي حرب
روسيا واوكرانيا حرب روسيا واوكرانيا
التغير المناخي فيروس كورونا عوامل ساهمت
في الاضطرابات
لكن لم تخلقها
احنا قدامنا اسئله كتير عنده
جدا
طيب ماشي
يعني انت رايك نكمل
لا
[ضحك]
طابت اوقاتك
الازمه اركان المحتل على مشروع ما تسميه
الدكتوره هبه جمال الدين صفقه القرن عبد
الله
الجد عبد الله الجد
[موسيقى]
انت يعني بتتكلم الدكتوره هبه جمال الدين
اه طبعا الصديقه العجوز اللي هي صاحبه بحث
الابراهيميه الشهير
[موسيقى]
ما هو الازمه الحاليه دي معناها ايه ان في
اضطرابات داخليه داخل اسرائيل
وانه في ازمه ان اليهودي يعيشوا مع بعض او
الاسرائيليين يعني اذا كانوا يهود او غير
الغالبيه طبعا يهوديه يعيشوا مع بعض بديله
والازمه دي عميقه مش هيكون بقى في قدره
انه يفكر ازاي انا انتشر واسيطر على غيري
اذا كنت انا مش قادر اسيطر على الارض اللي
انا عايش عليها ده انطباع الاول يعني
لكن ممكن الدكتوره هبه تيجي وتكلمكم
بنفسها يعني اذا وقتها سمحه
عندي سؤال لك انت دايما بتقول الحل
بالنسبه للسعوديه هو التعايش مع ايران هل
تعتقد ان السعوديه ما حاولت مليون مره
الحوار مع ايران الاف المرات نتفق معهم
وينقضون عهودهم وعودهم
انا فعلا قلت كده
ولكن اخونا فرث
يمكن في سوق فهم اللي انا بقوله انا ما
بقولش انه السعوديين او غير السعوديين
ياخدوا الورود
ويقصفوها على الايرانيين ويرحبوا بكل
تصرفاتهم ما لا يمكن اقول كده ايران هتبقى
دوله زيها زي روسيا زي اي دوله تانيه لازم
الدول بتعيش مع بعض بكل الوسائل يعني ياخد
كل الاحتياطات الممكنه على الكويت
والسعوديه ومش انا مش عليهم ده هم هم
بيعملوا كده وهم عندهم افكارهم وعلمائهم
ومستشارينهم بيعملوا كده من غير يعني مش
مستنيين انا اقول لهم انه ياخد بكل اسباب
القوه يتسلح
ينوع حلفائه
يستعين بما بكل وسائل القوه والمواجهه
والتحوط ضد ايران وغير ايران
انما اللي انا كنت بقوله انه ايران فاكتور
لايف موجوده لا تتغير هتعمل فيها ايه كان
نظام الشركه كانت عامله مشكله جاءت الثوره
الاسلاميه هي عامله مشكله كلمه عامله
مشكله دي
مش ان هي دوله ظالمه والباقيين مظلومين زي
ما بيتم تصويرهم في الاعلام الانتيريانيا
هي فكره انه هو الدول بتتصرف مع بعض كده
مش تقدر تغيرها انت تقدر يعني لازم تقبلها
كفته وتبتدي تتعامل معه التعامل معها ان
احنا ممكن تعيشوا زي ما طب والناس عاشوا
ازاي مع تركيا يعني سوريا كانت عايشه ازاي
مع تركيا وهي واخده جزء من اراضيها قبل
2011 كانت واخده جزء من ارضيه محتله جزء
من اراضيها وعندها اطماع في شمال سوريا
وهي كانت عايشه ازاي مع سوريا وسوريا
بتحتضن مثلا حزب العمال الكردستاني اللي
بينغص على تركيا الاتنين عارفين ان كل
واحد بيضمر للاخر ما يضمر لكن لازم نعيش
فالتعايش ده مش معناه ان انا اعطيه ظهري
واعطيه الامان لكن انا بتعامل معاه بكل
وسائل الحذر
وباخد بكل اسباب القوه بس مش تبقى الحياه
مواجهه في مواجهه مواجهه دمرت ايران واضرت
بدول الخليج كثيرا
ده اللي انا قلته وبالتالي انت هتتعامل مع
ايران اذا كان يعني يعني اذا تم الوفاق
وتعاملك مع ايران معناه ان انت هتعمل فيتو
على ده وده وده وهتفرض عليهم عقوبات في
ناحيه لكن هتبقى العلاقات كويسه في ناحيه
والحياه تسير بص للعلاقه ما بين ايران
وروسيا روسيا بتسمح للمقاتلات
الاسرائيليه انها تضرب من الشيات ايرانيه
في سوريا وايران عارفه ده لانه روسيا لها
مصالح مع اسرائيل لكن مع ذلك يبقى روسيا
بتتخلى عنهم في الملف ده وتدعمهم في عشرات
الملفات الاخرى وايران تروح تديها الدرونز
اللي هي محتاجاه علشان روسيا تساعدها في
ملف واثنين وثلاثه واربعه ملفات اخرى شوف
العلاقه ما بين ايران وتركيا ايران تلحق
بهم الاذى في ملفات وتضرب ملفاتهم
وحلفائهم مثلا في العراق ولا في سوريا
وتركيا بتعمل نفس القصه
تضرب مصالحها في ارمينيا وفي اذرب ايجان
ويتصالحوا في ملفات اخرى لكن العلاقات مش
مقطوعه حاله الحرب مش وارده وبس ده اللي
انا بقوله يعني انا اسف ان انا قلت اجابه
انا يعني مع اوفر الاحترام اخونا في الراس
انا معترض على يعني منطق السؤال مع
احترامي ليه انت ما تصنفش الناس على انه
السعوديه ودول الخليج هي قوه العقل والخير
والسلام بلد شريره
طريقه التفكير دي هي منبع المشكله
والايرانيين اللي بيفكروا كده برضو عندهم
نفس الخلل الدوله دوله قوه اعتباريه بتشعر
بتتصرف مع الدول الاخرى بمبدا توازن القوه
ومصالحها وبترتكب كل دوله بترتكب ما
ترتكبه الدول الاخرى من من مشكلات يعني
لما يقولوا ايران بلد سيء جدا وتدخل في
شؤون الاخرين طب انت قول لي دوله واحده في
هذا العالم لا تتدخل في شؤون الاخرين الا
اذا كانت عاجزه فالكلام ده كلام بيتقال في
ما يتقالش فيه اللي على يعني بشكل عقلاني
يعني السعوديه بتتدخل في شؤون الاخرين
ومصر بتتدخل في شؤون الاخرين والمغرب
والجزائر وتركيا
وبيتدخلوا في شؤون ايران وبيقلبوا
الاقليات اللي موجوده هناك وبيخترقوا كل
القوى اللي موجوده هناك وبيضغطوا على
الدول فبالتالي هم عارفين ان ده بيحصل
وانه اذا كان هذا العالم غابه زي ما كان
بيقول عمرو موسى فدول الخليج ليست قطط وهم
بيستخدموا كل الوسائل المتاحه اليهم
وطبيعي دي يعني فالتعامل مع ايران الافضل
ان يتم بانه بما اننا موجودين على ضفتاي
هذا الخليج انه نحاول نتفاهم بقدر ما
نستطيع ونتعاون بقدر ما نستطيع ونوسع
مساحات التعاون
قيصر بيقول او سيزر بيقول لماذا بريطانيه
الاكثر وحشيه في عدائه لروسيا من كل
الاوروبيين
سؤال طيب هي الاكثر للسببين
لتلات اسباب اولا هي ابعد من الدول الاخرى
عن الاروسيا فانت مش خسران حاجه انت موجود
هناك وهي بعيده ومش هتتاثر كثير قوي الا
اذا اوروبا كلها اتاثرت فهي مش هرمانه او
خسرانه كتير واحد اتنين
انه لما اندلعت الازمه كان برج جونسون
عنده ازمات داخليه وجت بعدها
الوزير اللي قعدت وزيره الخارجيه اللي
قعدت القسم الاسف هربان من زين اللي قعدت
42 يوم كان عندها ازمات داخليه وجاء
سوناك في جو ملتهب عاوز يغالي فيه برضو
على من سبقوه في حاله عدم استقرار فهم
بيستغلوا هذه المبالغه برضو لاسباب داخليه
ان انا بشغل الداخل بقضيه خارجيه تلاته
وهو انه بريطانيا بعد ان خرجت من الاتحاد
الاوروبي عاوزه تقول الاوروبيين ولا
الامريكان ان انا كارت مهم جدا وبالتالي
حافظوا على علاقتكم معي وان انا قادر ان
انا اكون مؤثره عسكريا ودبلوماسيا وقادره
اعمل اللي ممكن تعجزوا عليه في الدفاع عن
مصالحكم بدون امريكا انا اقدر العب دور
مهم وبالتالي عم بقع لقدكم معايا ودي فكره
جلوبال ان انا بعد
ان انا هلعب دور كوني يرجعني وكاني دوله
عظمى يعني
[موسيقى]
دي الاسباب يعني الاساسيه اللي بتخليها ان
هي طبعا في اسباب تانيه ان هي امبراطوريه
سابقه كانت لها دور اساسي تاريخي في
استقلال اوكرانيا سنه 94 وفي الاتفاق
الموقع الاستقلال اوكرانيا هي تستقل في
مقابل مجموعه من الشروط منها ان هي تتنازل
عن السلاح النووي وتسلمه
كان موجود يعني
هل التصالح السعودي الايراني يسهل دخول
السعوديه للبيكس
ولهذا السبب الصين كانت طرف
هو التصالح الصعود الايراني ما دمت بتتكلم
مساله يعني
[موسيقى]
مش قادر اتخيل انه السعوديه اصلا من غير
هذا التصالح
والله ممكن لان هو اصله برضو نرتب المساله
كده قبل ما نتكلم على
التصالح السعودي الايراني اولا هو مصلحه
لايران مصلحه للسعوديه بس هو مصلحه
للسعوديه اكثر بصراحه حتى الان لانه انا
مش قادره اتخيل
انا بقول حتى الان لان قد يكون هناك من
الاتفاقات السريه ما لا نعلمها تخيل معايا
الاتفاق ده لو تم
معناه انه ايران هيساعدوا السعوديه في
تقليل التوتر في اليمن ودي اكبر مشكله
بالنسبه للسعوديين ان يقللوا من تشجيع
الجامعات المؤيده لهم في العراق وفي سوريا
في انه يهدوا الاجواء
طيب
انه يكون في تعهدات ايرانيه بعدم اثاره
الاضطرابات الامنيه ولا العسكريه لدول
الخليج ما هو ده مصادر الخلافه الرئيسيه
انه يكون الخليجيين طرف اساسي في اي اتفاق
نووي في المستقبل طب في المقابل هتحصل على
ايه امور دي كلها هي اللي بتخلي لها نفوس
الايرانيين هياخدوا ايه انه يوقفوا لهم
قناه ايران انترناشونال اللي هي مؤثره
يعني في الاضطرابات الداخليه في ايران
الاضطرابات الداخليه في ايران مبالغ في
تغطيتها جدا في الاعلام العربي طيب
هيعملوا ايه هيستثمروا في ايران ده يبقى
عظيم جدا بس ممكن يستثمره لايران ويخاطروا
بالتعرض لعقوبات امريكيه امر مشكوك فيه هل
ممكن بمجرد ما يبدا الاتفاق تضخم مليارات
الدولارات وممكن تروح امر مش منطقي
فاستشعر انه حتى الان انه هو ايران
هتستفيد انه يكون تهدئه بس مش هتستفيد
كتير السعوديه هتستفيد اكتر تهدئه يعني
انتصار دبلوماسي يعني استثمارات هتجيلها
اكتر وهي بتجيلها استثمارات يعني
بتمهد لفكره ان هي ما تتعرضش لاي اضطرابات
لامنيه ولا ارهابيه ولا عسكريه اعتقد انها
الطرف الفائز حتى الان ما لم يكن هناك
اتفاقات اخرى لا نعلمها بالنسبه لايران
بالنسبه
اذا استقرت الاوضاع
وبدات السعوديه تبقى اكثر انتعاشا وماشيه
في مشروعها الكبير مش تلاقي اي سبب ما
يخليهاش تنضم للبريكس اذا فتحت بريكس
ابوابها لانها يعني اخر عضو قابلته كان
[موسيقى]
كان جنوب افريقيا اظن في 2009
اس بريكس اس لكن سوت افريكا في 2009
نتحدث كثيرا وباكثر من حلقه ان مكاسب
اقتصاد اي دوله قائم بشكل اساسي على
الناتج المحلي وانه من خلال هذا المقياس
نعرف حجم الاقتصاد اي دوله ولكن الاحظ
بطرحك الجميل انك تستثني بعض الدول من هذا
لم افهم يا صديقي اي دول استثنيهم انا ما
بقولش ان هو
مقياس اي اقتصاد انا بقول ان هو مؤشر واضح
وبسيط لفهم حجم اقتصاد دوله ما انت
النهارده لما تيجي عمال تقول لي مثلا انا
دوله عظمى انا دوله كبيره ويكون الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي بتاعك يعني
متواضع جدا يبقى لازم
لازم تعيد النظر ما انت بتقول لي انا عندي
مصنع ومصنع كبير يعني كبير ده بانهي معيار
على مستوى الشارع اللي عندي ولا على مستوى
المدينه ولا على مستوى الدوله على مستوى
العالم مصنعك بانتاجه او
اصوله قد كده فانت لما
الجيلي بي بيقول لك انت كلك على بعضك دخلك
كلك قد ايه فده احد المعايير الاساسيه
فده من حيث اهميه
ولما بتشوف الجي بي بتاخد اعتبارات اخرى
بتاخد اعتبار عدد السكان الزياده السكانيه
بتاخد
عداله التوزيع بتاخد مصادر التوزيع زياده
الجي دي بي جايه منين جاي من مصادر تنميه
حقيقيه ولا اقتراض ولا ايه يعني بتحلل
الرقم يعني انما اذا رعيت فيه اعتبارات
كثيره يعني بيعبر عن
وضع الاقتصاد في دوله ما انا بستثني اي
دول قل لي بس والانهي دوله وانا معاك
والله انا تحت امرك
يعني انا
وضح لي قصدك وانا ارد عليك
ميسن بيقول معسكر عدم الانحياز هل هو
الخيار الافضل لدول الجنوب العالمي مثل
مصر وهل توحيد معسكر من هذا النوع قد ينجح
في اجبار الولايات المتحده على اتخاذ موقف
اكثر حياديه في القضيه الفلسطينيه او
علاقتها بالعرب
هو يعني
الاجابه انه الدول الاجابه لادق شويه اصل
انا لما اقول معسكر عدم الانحياز
يعني انا كاني بقول ان في دول بتتجه الى
عدم الانحاس بالمعنى التاريخي اللي تاسس
يعني اثناء الحرب البارده انما هو الادق
ان الدول اللي زي اللي انت بتشير اليها
مصر ودول الشرق الاوسط والهند وكل اللي
انت وصفتهم
بمعسكر الجنوبي العالمي او الجلوبل
الافضل لهم وهم يفعلوه ان هم
ينضموا للمعسكر بشكل ترانزكشنال يعني
منفعي اذا كان لي مصلحه مع امريكا اخدها
اذا كان لها مصلحه مع روسيا اخدها اذا كان
اللي هي مصلحه مع الصين اخذها وهكذا انا
مش انا مع امريكا على طول اللي قاعد مع
امريكا على طول ما كسبش حاجه واللي راهن
على روسيا فقط ولا الوقت او الصين ممكن ما
يكسبش حاجه فكل واحد زي الهند كده الهند
بتلعب الدور ده بشكل الامارات دلوقتي
بتعمله يعني هي بتستفز الامريكان هي كانت
حليف امريكي
بامتياز ثم جاءت في السنوات الاخيره ديت
يعني هي بتتعامل مع امريكا وتسر على
التعامل وتوسيع العلاقات مع روسيا
وعايشه بارتي حفله مع الصين في
برضو حاجه تحسب للامارات ولكل الدول اللي
بدات انها تعمل ده مصر بتعمله السعوديه
بتعمله دول الخليج بصفه عامه بقت تعمله
[موسيقى]
فهذا امر جيد
وفي دول ما بتستفزش الدول الاخرى يعني
المغرب مثلا هي شايفه ان مصالحها اكتر
معاه الغرب بالاسباب مفهومه انما بتحاول
ان هي ما تستفزش الروس وتوزع علاقتها مع
الصين برضو
ومحمد سعد حذف الرساله كنت عاوز تكتب ايه
يا محمد
عمر مساء الخير استاذ سيد لماذا الدول
العربيه
في التحالف مع الصين
اليس امريكا على عيوبها افضل من الصين
لقياده العالم
سؤال كبير يا عمر كبير بمعنى انه يعني ما
فيش اجابه واضحه عليهم ولكن امريكا زي بغض
النظر هي احسن ولا اوحش
الدول العربيه في مجملها عانت من سياسه
امبراطوريه افسدها
احتياج الدول العربيه للولايات المتحده
والقوه المطلقه لامريكا الدول عانت كثيرا
من الولايات المتحده وضغوطها واستعلاءها
وانحيازها الواقح مع اسرائيل النفاق الفج
ان هي تتكلم عن قيم وفي نفس الوقت القيم
دي لا تنطبق ابدا على مصالح امريكا ولا
على استفزازات اسرائيل
الشروط المكحفه اللي في التعاملات لصالح
الشركات الامريكيه كتير يعني
يكون في عالم متعدد الاقطاب يعني لما يكون
زي ما بيحصل شويه دلوقتي لو حاخذها من
الصين مش هديك هذا السلاح الا بشروط اروح
لروسيا بس ادي كل الفكره يعني انما اكيد
لو بقت في قوه مطلقه لقطب واحد القوه
مفسدها القوه المطلقه مفسده اكيد يعني
هل توقف دول الخليج عن تقدير هل التوقف
دول الخليج عن تقديم المزيد من الدعم لمصر
وهو ياس من السياسات الاقتصاديه المصريه
اما ابتزاز سياسي لاجبار مصر على تحقيق
مطالب معينه لاخونا سيزر مره تانيه انا ما
اعرفش انه انا عارف ان كان في توتر بس
انتم سالتوني قبل كده وانا سالتهم وما
عرفش سبب واضح قوي ان يكون في مشكله عميقه
المشكله دي كانت تتعلق بالسعوديه بشكل
رئيسي مش كل دول الخليج وهي حاجات بتحصل
بشكل دوري انما اللي اقدر اقوله لك
كالتالي اللي انا اعرفه مش اللي ما
اعرفهوش اكيد اللي ما عرفوش ممكن يكون
كتير بس ما اعرفوش فمقدرش افتي فيه
انه دول الخليج في الفتره الاخيره عندها
منطقه ده في حدود معلوماتي انه ايا كان
المساعدات لدوله تعدادها اكثر من 100
مليون لازم تكون مقضيه وعشان تكون مجديه
مفيش رقم ممكن يكون مجدي يؤدي الى نتيجه
نهائيه بلد في 100 مليون بلد ضخم قد كل
دول الخليج مرتين وبالتالي لازم تكون في
بوضوح في المساله انا عاوز مثلا اساعد مش
هتبقى العمليه انه ادفع مليار اتنين مليار
ااا وبعدين تتجدد المشكله مره اخرى
خصوصا ان الدول التي تحتاج الى مساعدات
كثيره والدول اللي عندها فائض محدوده
فالدول ديت عندها تصورات عاوزه تراعى
وعندها ايضا مصالح عاوزه تراعي يعني عاوز
انت اساعدك انا هستثمر عندك ما هو ما فيش
ما فيش فلوس هتدفع انا عاوز استثمر استفيد
استفيد وانت تستفيد عشان تستفيد انا عندي
تصورات للاستفاده القيم الحقيقيه للاصول
القيمه الحقيقيه للجنيه اللي انا هشتري به
مناخ الاستثمار اللي انا هعمل فيه حجم
المنافسه مع الشركات المملوكه للدوله انا
يكون عندي فرصه حقيقيه ولا لا نظام القضاء
اللي انا هعمل به اضمن لي حقي بطيء ولا
سريع كل الحاجات دي حاجات مقبوله ومفهومه
وفي حدود معلومات ان الحكومه لا تجادل
فيها الحكومه المصريه وبتسعى اليها التحدي
كبير هياخد وقت اتمنى ان الامور
واتعشى من ده يحصل يعني يتم التغلب عليها
انما مش متخيل قوي يعني الكلام كبير يعني
لانه في الاخر عدد الدول الواقفه على
قدميها محدود للخليج يقدر يستغنى عن مصر
ولا مصر تقدر تستغنى عن دول الخليج واتمنى
ان ده ميحصلش يعني
هل اصبحت الشعوب
هل اصبحت الشعوب او
يعني مفهوم السؤال ادريس انه
يعني انا تقريبا انه الديمقراطيه الحريه
في مؤشر الديمقراطيه
بس احنا اتكلمنا على القصه دي يمكن من
ثلاث اربع سنين ان في دول ديمقراطيه ما هو
حتى في بعض الدول الديمقراطيه بقت حاسه مع
الازمات الاقتصاديه ومع الهجره ومع وجود
طيار
طيارات قوميه بتقول بولندا للبولنديين
وهولندا للهولنديينه بقى فكره الديمقراطيه
اللي هي تدي المواطنه لاي حد والحدود
مفتوحه بقت فكره ضد افكار التيار اليميني
اللي بقى قلقان من التغير على الساحه
الدوليه اه
في تغيرات طبعا ده غير صالح الديمقراطيه
اللي انت كنا بنشوفها وشايفين ان هي حاجه
عظيمه يعني
مساء الخير الاستاذ سيد في حال حصل امر
عظيم يجعل من امريكا تنكب على معالجه
امورها الداخليه والالتفات عن اي شيء اخر
البراك تستطيع اسرائيل ان توجه حرب لو
كانت تقدر بدون جسر لو كانت امريكا لو
كانت اسرائيل تقدر العمل ده
المساله صعبه على اسرائيل يعني انا تحارب
حزب الله ولا تعمل مساله صعبه ومكلفه
سواء بدعم امريكا وبدون دعم امريكا بقى
الوضع اصعب
لا داعي اسرائيل تحتل الاردن محتله من قبل
امريكا ولها ثمن قواعد في شرق الاردن لا
اعلم هذه المعلومه يا صديقي هل حكومه
نتنياهو تحاول تصدير ازمتها الداخليه
للخارج مثل ايران حتى الان لا حتى الان مش
شايفين ده هم بيضغطوا على ايران من الاول
ونفس الضغط بنفس المستوى
اللي خلصنا كده
ما شاء الله هذا عدد هائل طب ارجع تاني
ازاي انا عملت كده افتكرت ان انا خلصتها
انا خايف لاحسن حد يقول ان انت تجاهلت
سؤالي طيب انا السؤال اللي ظاهر لي دلوقتي
مساء الخير انا عملت كده في بعض الاسئله
مش مقصوده والله مساء الخير فكره ان روسيا
ده سلمان القطوان فكره ان روسيا تعتبر
تركيا الجائزه الكبرى
كيف لروسيا ان تستحل دوله عسكريه بهذا
الحجم
العلم انها فكره سائده فكيف يمكن ان يحصل
ذلك انا مش فاهم يا اخويا سلمان
يعني تقصد انه مين قال انه روسيا بتحاول
السيطره على تركيا
هي بتحاول اذا كان ده مفهوم السؤال روسيا
عارفه انه تركيا بلد مهم جدا لحلف شمال
الاطلسي وهو
سن الرمح يعني لحلف شمال الاطلسي وواحد من
اهم ثاني اهم جيش يعني ما بحبش الفكر
التاني والتالت ديت جيش كبير ومهم وهي
تعتقد انه في التوجهات اللي موجوده في
تركيا
بتخليها على تناقضات مع حلف شمال الاطلسي
اللي معظم دول من الاتحاد الاوروبي اللي
رفض تركيا وان تركيا بحكم طبيعتها كدوله
اسلاميه وفيها حزب ده تتوجه له قاعده
اسلاميه كبيره هيبقى دايما في تناقضات مع
الغرب بتحاول ان هي تستميل كل ما استملته
وكل ما التناقضات والمشاكل بين تركيا
واوروبا زادت روسيا مبسوطه كل ما زاد
التعود مع تركيا رغم الخلافات الكبيره
بينها وبين روسها يكون احسن ده اللي انا
بس لكن لو لك سؤال محدد استاذنك ابعته
هل ستدفع اوكرانيا ثمن الاسلحه التي
اخذتها من الغرب والله انا نفسي اسال
السؤال ده برضو ده في سؤال اصعب
طبعا نسيت حاجه يعني لكن واضح ان في حاجات
مسجله كديون لكن
يعني انت النهارده بيتكلموا على اعمار
يتجاوز كانوا كاتبين كام
400 اظن 400 وكان رقم كده حد بيحدده بشكل
يبدو ان هو عامل دراسه
بالدولار يعني 412 حاجه زي كده مليار
دولار مين اللي هيدفع كل هذا الرقم وبعدين
نزلنسكي عنده الاعتقاد ان انا بحارب
بالنيابه عنكم زي ما صدام حسين كان بيقول
لدول الخليج يجب ان تدفعه في فتره ما كثير
مما دفعته العراق في مواجهه ايران
طبعا دول الخليج قالت له انا ما قلتلكش
حرب ايران يعني لكن احنا دعمناك اه لكن دي
قصه يعني فهو
اعطوني سلاحا اعطوني مالا اعطوني الان
بسرعه الوقت وبعدين كثير دول الغربيه يقول
والله المساله صعب ان احنا نستمر كده كتير
[موسيقى]
هم ضحوا باوكرانيا كلها على بعض وهذا
الزلنسكي بقى يعني سامحه الله من جانب
الاوكرانيين هلا الحرب على الارهاب في
سيناء انتهت اعتقد على الاقل انها تراجعت
بشكل كبير جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا
سايب هل من جديد بخصوص الصلح بين السعوديه
وايران تسير الامور بشكل جيد حتى الان هم
قالوا شهرين من 10 مارس تعود السفارات
ويلتقي وزيري الخارجيه خلال هذا رمضان ده
جيد والتفاوض مع سوريا برضه نقطه جيده ولو
اني مش شايف ان في ارهاصات جيده جيده في
اليمن يعني
حتى الان
لماذا لا تتعاود اسرائيل وتركيا والسعوديه
لاسقاط نظام بشار وايت الله الخميني
متعاونوا تعاونت اسرائيل مع دول كثيره لا
تركيا برا الموضوع لكن تعاونت اسرائيل
والسعوديه وبعض دول الخليج والولايات
المتحده ودول اوروبيه
واضرب ايتان
ما نجحوش يعني
كيف نستفيد بالانتخابات المصريه القادمه
وتعيين خالد
خالد بن زايد وليا للعهد صحيح مساله تعيين
ولي عهد جديد لغايه انا النهارده انا لم
اقرا هذا الخبر ما اعرفوش قد يكون صحيحا
وقد يكون غير صحيح
وبالتالي ليس لدي ما اضيف في هذا الصلاه
كيف نستفيد الانتخابات المصريه من نحن حتى
نستفيد يعني انت مصري وعاوز تستفيد
بالانتخابات المصريه ولا انت جنسيتك حاجه
تانيه يا استاذ عبده وبعدين عن اي
انتخابات مصريه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
القادمه يعني
السلام عليكم معكم مروان استاذ سيد رمضان
مبارك الله يخليك
وتقبل الله طاعتنا وطاعتك سؤالي بخصوص
تعدد الاقطاب الا ترى من مصلحتنا كدول
العالم ثالث سقوط اقطاب متعدده سيمكننا من
تحقيق مصالحنا ايوه طبعا احنا لسه كنا
بنقول عالم متعدد التعامل مع الاقطاب
الكبيره عندك حاجه عندك عماله ماهره تقول
لهم اعملوا لي استثمارات وانا عندي
المهندسين وعندي الحرفيين وعند الاطباء
وعندي رجال القانون وعند الامن
لازم يكون عندك حاجه لازم يكون عندك دوله
مستقره لازم يكون عندك شرعيه بحيث ما
يكونش في اضطرابات وقلق لازم يكون عندك
كده يعني والا الناس دي هتجيلك ليه ما انا
انا بجيلك لسبب
علشان كده لما حصلت ازمه وضغوط كتير على
الصين وقالوا هننقل الاستثماراتنا الغربيه
لدول اخرى كان السؤال طب مين الدوله
اللي ممكن تستقبل مئات المليارات من
الدولارات في مصانع في تكنولوجيات متقدمه
ونصف متقدمه وتجد هذه العماله والبيئه
التشريعيه والوضع الامني اللي موجود في
الصين مساله صعبه مش سهله يعني مش سهله ان
انت تروح ناقل بس كده مصانع تروح لمصانع
لدوله ما فيش فيها امن ودائما موجود على
كف عفريت ممكن تحصل فيها اضطرابات تاني
يوم ولما يكون هي
الامن موجود ما فيش بيئه تشريعيه تيجي
تستثمر تتوه في متاهات الاستثمار تيجي
ترجع للقضاء القضاء يعطلك السنين تيجي
تنفذ الاحكام ما تعرفش تنفذها تيجي تصدر
ما تلاقيش بنيه تحتيه حاجات كثيره علشان
تقدر تعيش في دول متعدده الاقطاب او حتى
قطب واحد
انا استاذنكم هنقف بعد خمس دقايق
عشان ندي للناس كمان فرصه اللي عاوز يقضي
وقت لطيف في رمضان بعيدا عن هذا الكلام
يعني
الكلام السياسي والاقتصادي السلام عليكم
فيصل من السعوديه هل التصالح السعودي
الايراني يسهل دخول السعوديه اجلنا على
هذا السؤال
ده اه بيكمل هو بقى
ولهذا وما هو الفرق بين التصالح السعودي
الحالي وفي السابق كان متصالحين يوجد
تبادل سفراء ايوه يا صديقي صحيح والله
السؤال ده جميل يا اخونا اولا السؤال يسهل
البريكس احنا اجابنا انه اتخيل لو البريكس
فتح ابوابه ده يكون عامل اضافي لانه
استقرار لدولتين وبالتالي هيبقى في مصلحه
الدوله تاني انما الفرق بين التصالح ده
والتصالح السابق التصالح في حد ذاته اذا
كان يقصد رجوع السفره فهو حاجه محدوده جدا
جدا لانه
البلدين شهدوا في الصول من اسوا
فترات توتر العلاقه بين السعوديه
وايران وكان السفره موجودين وجود السفره
والسفرات لا يعني انه الامور بقت عظيمه
لكن في ظل ان مفيش سفره من سبع سنين اللي
يرجع السفره ويلتقي المسؤولين ويتعهدوا
بخفض التوتر هذه مجرد البدايه فقط ولا
تعني نهايه واحتواء كل المشاكل ولكن بدايه
رحله محاوله ايه راس الصدر
ما هي طبيعه العلاقه بين السعوديه ولبنان
علاقه قديمه جدا جدا فيها
يعني سياسيه اقتصاديه تجاريه كثيره لانه
لبنان بلد صغير
خلينا صديقه صحفيه لبنانيه تقول لي ادي
الفاره ويملى الحاره يعني بلد صغير بس
يعني مسموع يعني
قصه طويله بس مثلا
لبنان السعوديه غير ان عندها استثمارات
ضخمه هناك مش قادره تتخيل بس لان لبنان
تتحول الى قاعده لبنانيه
مش هتقدر تتخيل في الخمسينات انها تبقى مع
القوميه العربيه مع جمال عبد الناصر فده
يضرها مش هتقدر تتخيل ان هي تنشئ جماعه
معاديه للمصالح السعوديه فتضرب المصالح
السعوديه في لبنان وفي غير لبنان كل ده
يضرها يعني الاستثمارات الضخمه اللي في
الصوفيه لبنان او اللي ممكن تبقى ضخمه
بالعلاقه مع سوريا ما هو
وامتداداتها بقى العلاقه مع سوريا
وابتديتها مع ايران ومع اوروبا قصه طويله
يعني لكن في النهايه
يعني السعوديه برضو جربت زي ما جربت مع
ايران فكره العلاقه القويه جدا انها تدعم
يغرها لبنان في كل في كل الاحوال فوجدت
انه هي بتدعم لبنان ومن يفوز هو ايران ثم
جربت قطيعه لبنان فوجدت انه هي بتخسر دوله
كبيره دوله دوله مهمه مش دوله كبيره يعني
لصالح برضو الايرانيين اللي مستعدين ان هم
يعيشوا في هذا الخراب ويتعلموا ذلك فقالت
لا انا هحاول اصلح اموري مع ايران مع
سوريا ومع لبنان هذا افضل لي على كل
الصعده ومع ذلك دي مساله تحتاج الى كثير
من التفصيل انا اكثر من شاكر لكم وانا
عارف ان في اسئله تانيه كثيره بس احنا بقى
لنا ساعتين على الهواء وانا مش عاوز
ربنا يخليك يا ابراهيم الهلالي اشكرك على
كلامك الطيب
لكن سامحوني يعني ان شاء الله استاذنكم في
استكمال الاجابه على اسئلتكم باذن الله في
البث المباشر القادم ومن خلال الحلقات
المقبله واعتذر بشده على الاسئله اللي انا
ما تمكنتش من الاجابه عليها وان شاء الله
موجودين مع بعض في الاسابيع المقبله ان
احيانا الله اسعد الله ليلتكم وشكرا جزيلا
لكم وشكرا جزيلا ماندو ربنا يخليك بدونك
البث يبقى صعب جدا